Exzellent, genau, so sieht's aus.
By the way, wer hätte es nicht erkannt, das ist kein Windows XP im Hintergrund.
Muss man doch mal sagen, sonst kommt die ersten Leute mit der mChat an.
Max, ich hab dich durchschaut!
Das ist kein XP, deswegen sag ich jetzt mal, ja das ist kein XP.
Man weiß ja nie mittlerweile.
So.
Exzellent, erst mal kurz die Mode-Größe einstellen.
Kein XP, also noch nicht.
Ja, und zwar, ich hab doch mal so ein Video gemacht, Windows 98.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt, äh, Dino 890 an Windows 98.
Das da.
Falls das jemand gesehen hat.
Falls das jemand gesehen hat, das war ja recht, das war ja recht beliebt.
Vor allem, wie ich PCMR einfach im Titel hab.
PCMR, naja gut.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach so ein Video jetzt auch zu Windows XP.
Den Rest kam, also ganz ehrlich, das war ja recht beliebt.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach so ein Video jetzt auch zu Windows XP, den Rest kam, also ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ich Windows 98 gezeigt hab, ich muss kein 95 zeigen, ich muss kein ME zeigen und ich muss auch Windows 2000 zeigen.
Also ich glaub, das Nächste Interessante ist wieder XP.
Ich hab schon ganz lange kein Windows XP mehr gehabt.
Deswegen, also es gibt, Windows XP hätte man noch die Möglichkeit, den Gramm zu installieren auf echten, auf echten Hardware.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob wir das wirklich machen sollten.
Weil echte Hardware ist immer so ein Ding, da geht dann wahrscheinlich die Hälfte am Endeffekt nicht.
Windows 2000 ist ein Businessbetriebssystem.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Es gab Geldautomaten, die laufen, oder es gibt Geldautomaten, die laufen immer noch mit XP, ja.
Und es gibt bestimmt auch genug Bankingzeug und so was und Industriesteuerungsgedöns, das mit 2000 läuft.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, wo kriegen wir denn den ISO her?
Service Pack 2, es gibt gar keinen Service Pack 3, was ist das?
Das ist der Schwache, es gibt keinen Service Pack 3, es gibt nur Service Pack 2.
So, erstmal hier, Download, excellent.
Wie einfach.
Nein, Windows, das ist das Falsche.
Komm mal hier, Windows XP runterladen, und was laden Sie mir runter?
Windows 2003, die Microsoft PP Gas.
Was?
What the fuck?
Vielleicht soll ich doch mal auf die Seite gehen, den Download wieder abbrechen.
Thank you for downloading.
Nein, nein, nein, ich brauch, ich brauch, ich brauch die Windows XP ISO.
Es gab keinen SP3, bring ich das jetzt durch?
Es gab keinen, Schwachsinn, es gab keinen Windows 7 SP3, so rum war's, ne?
Ja, die Windows 7 war's, genau, stimmt, natürlich.
Windows XP gab's einen Service Pack 3.
Weil ich weiß noch, wo die Chip damals, übelste Rotz-Zeitung, wo die damals Windows 7 SP3 rausgebracht haben.
Und dann hat Microsoft, glaub ich, die damals sogar abgemahnt, weil die gesagt haben,
kann es nicht sein, dass ihr das SP3 nennt, wenn es gar kein SP3 ist.
Gestern war lustig, die Keks-Support-Hotline, wieso hat auch gut funktioniert.
Hast du den, hast du den Majora's Mask-Speeder?
Ich bin eingepennt, ich hab das heute Nacht irgendwie auf dem Handy gesehen, irgendwann.
Da hab ich halt, ich bin dann aber eingepennt.
Ich hab das laufen auf dem Handy teilweise zwischendurch.
Z-Pudding, 11 Monate, exzellent Subscription.
Der Desktop ist der beste Desktop.
Will mir irgendjemand sagen, dass das nicht der beste Desktop ist?
Wer hat, Chet, habt ihr etwa einen besseren Desktop zu bieten?
Das glaub ich euch nicht.
Picks all didn't happen.
Bester.
Darf man überhaupt noch Pok-Emotes zeigen?
Darf man überhaupt noch Pok-Emotes zeigen jetzt?
Oder ist das direkt Monka-Toss?
Übrigens Leute, ich hab die, ich hab alle,
Pok-Emotes bis auf Pok-O habe ich alle hinzugefügt über
BetterTwitchTV, weil BetterTwitchTV hat gesagt...
Moment.
Oder auch nicht.
Ach nee, hier, genau.
Weil BetterTwitchTV hat gesagt, sie entfernen keine Emotes.
Oder hab ich jetzt einfach mal alle Emotes umgestellt,
die wir hatten, alle Pok-Emotes umgestellt auf
BetterTwitchTV von FFZ.
Was auch nicht schlecht ist, jetzt hab ich bisschen mehr free...
bisschen mehr freie, ähm...
als wenn man auf Cached geht.
Der Download, der ist hartnäckig mit dem Kram unterzuschieben, oder?
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Also, guck mal, guck mal.
Wenn Microsoft selbst schon debatet...
Wenn Microsoft selbst schon debatet, zu geil.
Oder meint ihr, Microsoft hat sich vertan?
Ja, ich weiß.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Mal gucken, was heute richtet.
Der aktuelle Pok-Champ ist immer noch der gleiche von gestern.
Langweilig.
Den find ich, den find ich nicht gut.
Okay, wir versuchen jetzt mal,
was auf der Microsoft-Seite zu finden,
ansonsten gehen wir irgendwie archive.org oder so was.
Windows, Windows XP ISO Download.
Download Service Pack 2.
Jawoll.
Windows XP Profes... Together?
Äh...
Ich weiß nicht so genau,
ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Das ist nur SP?
Alter, Microsoft!
Alter, ihr könnt mich mal...
Schiebt mir doch nicht immer den Kram...
Leute, komm, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach nur falsch benannt.
Die sind einfach nicht in der Lage, bei Microsoft den Kram richtig zu benennen.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus. Easy.
Wir laden jetzt Windows 2003 runter und hoffen, es ist Windows XP.
Das ist ja dann quasi...
So, wir müssen mal ein paar VMs löschen.
Ein paar Olle.
Jaja.
Alles gut. Remove.
Können wir auch löschen.
Braucht Platz.
Wo hatten wir denn hier was?
Ah, die gibt's wieder.
C Double User Documents.
Warum hab ich die Dinger überhaupt lokal hier liegen?
Die müssen alle weg.
So viel Olle VMs.
Äh... Power off.
Sag mal, wo hab ich denn die liegen? Open VM?
Hier.
Sieb in...
Ok, jetzt kommt alles weg.
Zack.
Die oberen zwei brauchen wir im Prinzip.
Der ganze Müll kann weg.
Hallo?
So, erst mal ein bisschen Platz machen wieder.
Weil ich glaub, ich hab gar nicht...
Ich hab zumindest auf C gar nicht mal so viele Sachen.
So, und den Kram können wir auch löschen.
Den brauchen wir auch nicht.
Die Distribution hat mich ja echt enttäuscht.
Ähm, Leute.
Was sagt ihr zu VMs?
Sagt ihr VMs?
Oder sagt ihr VM?
VM.
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit jemand, der sagt auch nicht VM.
Wer sagt VM, wer?
Der Kopf war mal an 13 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exquisite Subscriptions.
13 Monate, das sind ja schon...
IQ++...
VM, ok.
Virtuelle Maschine.
Genau, ich spreche das auch immer korrekt aus.
Leute, heute, heute im Stream, passt auf.
Wir verwenden keine Abkürzungen.
Wir werden alles aussprechen.
Wir verwenden keine VMs, wir verwenden nur virtuelle...
Nein, das machen wir nicht, weil ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich das nicht auf die Reihe kriege.
Anasio1312, Prime Subscription, Massive Sub.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Gucken, ob ich nichts gesehen habe.
Heute ist Z-Pudding, 11 Monate, danke schon.
Falls ich nicht gesehen habe, aber...
Doppel, doppel IQ...
Was, was labere ich denn?
Ich wollte IQ++ sagen, dass mir aufgefallen ist, dass es keinen Sinn ergibt.
Auch danke für den Sub.
So, schnell durch Scrawlerman.
Scrawlerman ist am Start.
So, alles klar.
Dann sag mal, Windows XP und Abkürzung, das ist ja keine Abkürzung, das hat ja Microsoft abgekürzt.
Das muss ich ja nicht selbst abkürzen.
Ups, mein Chat ist weg.
Chat, ihr seid weg. Warum?
Ah, jetzt. Jetzt ist er wieder da.
Alles klar, den Gramm wollte ich auch wegschmeißen.
Vms, jawoll.
Löschen.
Remove.
Alles klar, so.
Wenn das funktioniert, vielleicht mach ich das echt auf echter Hardware.
Ich hab hier noch Hardware rumliegen.
Wartet mal, ich hab hier irgendwo...
Wartet mal.
Ich hab hier neben so ne Box unter den ganzen Konsolen stehen und ich glaube, da ist doch so ne ganz alte Zotac...
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz unter den Schreibtisch kriechen, ey.
So ne alte Zotac-Box.
Ja.
Alter, was ist denn das für ein Teil?
Das hat noch nicht mal HDMI-Ausgang.
What the fuck, das liegt ganz schön lange in der Karte auch schon rum.
Ähm, da könnte man Windows XP drauf installieren.
So ein richtig uralt Schrott-Ding, was wahrscheinlich aus den Zeiten von Windows XP kommt.
Zeig mal her, steht da irgendwie drauf, was das ist?
Zotac steht da nur drauf. Zotac.
Aber unten steht, unten steht drauf, wie das Teil heißt.
Also, passt mal auf.
Vielleicht installieren wir es sogar auf echter Hardware.
Das wäre natürlich richtig poggers.
Muss ich mal eine Capture-Card holen.
Zumindest würden dann auch irgendwelche Spiele und Sachen drauf funktionieren.
Also, das Ding nennt sich Zotac.
Zotac.
Dann mit SSD.
Äh.
Ey, wir installieren es erstmal in der VM.
Aber ich will erst mal gucken, was das für eine Kiste ist.
Zotac Z-Box ID.
42 BE.
Mit Bluetooth.
Richtig, richtig Bleeding-Edge-Technologie hier.
Genau, so sieht das Teil aus.
So sieht das Ding aus.
Was ist da drin?
Hä, das hat eine HDMI?
Moment.
Moment, das hat eine HDMI.
Okay, das hat echt eine HDMI.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Nee, das können wir gar nicht verwenden, weil ich kein passtes Netzteil dafür hab.
Aber wenn ich ein Video über Windows XP mach, dann installier ich es vielleicht sogar ernsthaft auf der Hardware.
Weil auf Hardware ist es einfach nicer.
Ich will es mir heute einfach nur mal angucken.
Also, was hatten die?
Das hat eigentlich einen Celeron.
Was ist denn das für ein Teil?
So alt ist es gar nicht.
Ist ungefähr so gut wie der PC vom Fabian.
So, also zeig mal her, was das ist.
Okay, okay.
Ja, es ist doch schon ein bisschen älter, das Ding.
Was war das für einer?
Wie viel?
Ey, immerhin, immerhin, ein Dual-Core, ein Dual-Core-Celeron, ja, war das schon mal.
2 mal 1,1 Gigahertz.
Das ist quasi so die Geschwindigkeit von einem Pentium 3 oder so.
Dafür hat er damals auch schon wenig Strom verbraucht.
Das kann man machen.
Also, ich glaube fürs Video installiere ich es dann mal da drauf.
Aber jetzt mal so ein bisschen ausprobieren, was man in einem Video machen kann, weil das
ja eigentlich das Ziel war, was ich habe.
Ich wollte mir das Ding jetzt mal installieren und mal gucken, was man in einem Video so zeigen
könnte.
Also, wenn ihr irgendeine Idee habt, was man unbedingt mit Windows XP ausprobieren muss,
dann sagt mal Bescheid.
Also, was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe, ist, ich werde den Kram erstmal installieren, ich
gucke, was der letzte Browser ist, der funktioniert hat.
Dann installiere ich vielleicht ein paar olle Demos, weil das war noch Zeit, wo es Demos
gibt.
Was meinst du, muss man für einen halbwegs vernünftigen XP Spiele-PC hinlegen?
Du meinst heute, wenn du wirklich jetzt etwas Neues kaufen willst, Windows XP geht, das
ist gar nicht so teuer, weil die Sachen, die bei Windows XP aktuell waren, die sind billig
heutzutage.
Wo du richtig viel Geld hinlegen musst, ist, wenn du ein Pentium 2 PC mit SLI, wo du 2
und sowas bauen willst.
Das ist teuer.
Guck mal, was das mittlerweile kostet.
Guckst du mal bei Ebay, wenn du die Häuser mit Voodoo 2 kaufen willst, das ist, naja,
okay, geht eigentlich.
Aber trotzdem, ich meine, für eine Grafikkarte, die einfach mal irgendwie 20, 22 Jahre alt
ist, Microsoft Pinball, oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Mit Kaya, nice, dass du dein Wege hierher gefunden hast.
So, Voodoo 2 gibt es hier noch, gibt es SLIs als SLI noch?
Ach stimmt, das war diese tolle SLI Bridge, was im Endeffekt aussieht wie ein kleines
IDE-Kabel.
Guck mal, heute sieht sowas so aus, jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn ihr die Auswahl habt zwischen
so einem SLI Adapter oder so einem SLI Adapter, also stellt sich doch die Frage, was man nimmt
gar nicht mehr, oder?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, chat, eindeutig das hier, also wenn das nicht der geilere SLI Adapter
ist als der hier, dann weiß ich auch nicht, der sieht so modern, glänzend und gut aus,
ja, und der sieht einfach alt, verdreht und gelb aus, also da gibt es ja eigentlich gar
keine große Frage, was man da nimmt.
Ja, guck mal, also du musst heutzutage, wenn du dir 2 Voodoo 2 kaufen willst, und die gehen
noch hoch im Preis, gehe ich mal von aus, ne, sofort kauf, du kannst 200 Euro ausgeben
für eine Grafikkarte, die 22 Jahre alt ist, hat, oder?
Das ist übrigens was, was ich unbedingt nochmal machen will, irgendwann dieses Jahr oder so,
ich wollte mir mal mein Traumpc bauen, als ich quasi angefangen, das stimmt nicht, angefangen
habe ich ein bisschen früher, aber ich wollte mir mal Traumpc bauen, aus der Zeit, wo ich
überhaupt kein Geld hatte, mir diesen PC zu kaufen, und das war halt so die Zeit, wo
Pentium 2 aktuell waren, Pentium 2 450, Voodoo 2 SLI, irgendeine TNT 1 Grafikkarte, ne,
das war eher 2000 rum, das war eher 2000 rum, das war früher, 1998, 1998, genau, ich weiß
das relativ gut, weil das war die Zeit, das, mit Röhren, natürlich mit Röhren, klar
mit röhrem Monitor, natürlich, am besten so ein olden Samsung, was war das damals, 21
Zoll, so ein fetten, das ist gar nicht so günstig, ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist wirklich
nicht so günstig, so ein Ola, CIT, Samsung, ne warte mal, war das überhaupt Samsung, ja
doch, da gibt es auch gar nicht mehr so viel, was waren die Größen damals, 14 Zoll, 15
Zoll, 17 Zoll, 19 Zoll, 21 Zoll, gab es damals schon 24 Zoll, weil der Kram wurde ja immer
schwerer mit der Zeit, also ich hatte einen 21 Zoll und das Ding, das war ultra schwer,
ich glaube es war 21 Zoll oder 22 Zoll, das ging, das ging gut und gern bis 100 Hertz,
ja, das war damals relativ Standard, dass die Dinger 85 Hertz plus und so hatten, aber
das ist ja auch bei einem, also bei einem CIT funktioniert es ja prinzipiell anders,
er baut ja wirklich noch das Bild komplett neu auf, Syncmaster, genau, also ihr seht
der Kram ist nicht billig, eBay Kleinanzeigen, was letzte Preis, ja, das habe ich, das will
ich unbedingt noch machen, ich baue mir mein Traumpc von 1998 zusammen, aber halt mit, aber
halt mit Windows 98 oder Windows ME, vielleicht mache ich sogar, vielleicht mache ich sogar
Windows ME drauf, so, Poggers Voodoo 2, SLI, huge, ok, next, zeige ich mal her, ja installieren
wir später, Windows, Windows XP, wo bin ich denn da, Professional, also Leute, wie gesagt,
wenn ihr irgendwelche Ideen habt, was wir machen können unter Windows XP, sag Bescheid,
ich brauche Ideen für das Video, XP, ich brauche Ideen für das Video, konnte Windows
XP sinnvoll mit mehreren CPU-Kernen umgehen, nee, nee, nicht X64, Windows XP, war nur X64,
ja doch, ich glaube Windows XP, da war das schon normal, oder, dass man, warte mal, wann
war Release Date, Windows XP, ja, doch, doch, das kann es, also kannst du mehrere CPU-Kerne
nehmen, nehmen wir mal drei Stück, mal gucken, ob so was schräg im Klarkommt, doch, es gab
eine X64-Version, ja, die gab es, aber das hat keiner verwendet, so, komm, Windows XP,
4GB war damals huge, 4GB, hast du gedacht, alter, wer braucht 4GB RAM, alter, 4GB, Movie-Maker,
genau, ich habe mein erstes YouTube-Video mit Movie-Maker gemacht, ähm, der Unterschied,
also bei Windows XP bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, ich glaube, oder, was war der
Unterschied zwischen Windows XP Home und Pro, Ultimate gab es damals, glaube ich, noch
gar nicht, äh, ich, ich kriege es aus dem Kopf nicht hin, ok, du kannst dich nicht
per Remote-Desktop verbinden, war das alles, wirklich, was passiert da, Windows XP, Basic
Support Package, ja, das hat noch nie irgendjemand, man konnte das nicht in Active Directory
hängen, ok, wie gesagt, Remote-Desktop ging, irgendwelche Server-Settings ging nicht, ja,
gut, aber ganz ehrlich, ich hatte eh nur immer Windows XP Professional, wie sich das
für die Profis gehört, ok, komm, legen wir das jetzt mal an, zack, dat, alles gut, auch
alles, IDE, na gut, meinetwegen, 40G sollte für Windows XP komplett ausreichen, aber
mein Single Disk spackt sonst manchmal so rum, so, den, den Drucker löschen wir und
den Rest lassen wir so, exellent, auf geht's, installieren wir Windows XP, Windows 7 Ultimate,
gar, äh, oh, I finished, jaja, ich habe gefinished, alles gut, äh, ich weiß schon gar nicht
mehr, was der Unterschied war zwischen Windows 7 Ultimate und normal und so, das war, glaube
ich, alles nicht so wild, no, go fort, Settings, oh, ISO Image, mal gucken, ob das jetzt, mal
gucken, ob das überhaupt die richtige ISO ist, die wir uns bei Microsoft besagt haben,
ich mein, Microsoft hat hier uns downlauten lassen unter, unter Windows XP, aber es kann
ja durchaus sein, dass das gar nicht stimmt, CD, das bootet nicht von der CD, warum nicht,
das ist das falsche, was wir runtergeladen haben, ok, also, nochmal neu, wo ist der
Download, wo ist der inner Windows XP Download, mach das jetzt, ich mach das jetzt von meiner,
von meiner Linux aus, da kann er nicht erkennen, dass ich unter Windows unterwegs bin und mir
komische ISOs zum Download, mich zu komischen ISOs redirecten, doch, doch, die hatten ein
bootable Image, ja klar, hatten die das, doch, doch, auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, das ist
einfach, das ist die CD, wo nur das Service Pack dabei ist, wo gar kein Installer drauf
ist, ok, big image of the day, alles klar, chat, ist das Corona, in Großaufnahme, so,
die explodiert, right mirray, edges, wir gehen nochmal, wir gehen nochmal, wir gehen
jetzt, also, ok, ok genau.
Dann gibt mal Official Download Link, das muss doch Microsoft auch haben, Google Drive,
es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Hier, guck mal, archive.org, XP Pro, sogar mit offizielem Image, also mit richtig Image,
Image.
Pet G hat es, ach da, ne das ist das Service Pack, das ist kein ISO, das ist nur, ne das
ist nur das Service Pack, wie, doch, ich lad mir jetzt hier von archive.org runter, easy,
alpha, fertig, ISO Image, bam, hier, Professional with Service Pack 3, CD, VL, X, Dings, da,
alles klar.
Das Gute ist, dass wir es unter Windows runterladen, da kann ich gleich mal ein MD5 so mit drüber
machen.
Und, äh, downloaden wir das jetzt?
Ah, yes, high speed, high speed, dann machen wir gleich mal ein MD5 so mit drüber und
gucken mal, ob das überhaupt das Windows XP Image ist, aber das muss doch auch Microsoft
zum Download haben.
Aha, ne, ich brauch noch nen Key, ich hab nen Key, den zeig ich euch aber im Stream
nicht.
Das konnte man auch nicht ohne Key installieren, hä, die sind so fail, ne, irgend so nen Dude
bei Microsoft fragt, wo kann ich das Windows XP ISO downloaden und die Antwort ist, äh,
wie wärs, wenn du Windows 10 runterlädst?
Das ist so typische Schwachsins-Foren-Antworten, die keiner braucht, so useless, so, so komplett,
die meisten Foren sind da eh richtig, richtig, richtig krass useless, was das angeht.
Am Letzten sind Artikel gelesen, ähm, wo war denn das, ich glaub der Standard war das,
das ist ja auch so ne Seite, wo man sich teilweise fragt, wo die das abschreiben, den Kram, was
war denn das, ich krieg das Thema gar nicht mehr zusammen, ich glaub es ging da drum,
äh, weil, weil Trump ja auf Twitter jetzt gesperrt wurde und da haben sie dann geschrieben
in diesem Text, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, um was der Artikel genau ging, ich
bin da über ihn ne Suche hingekommen und da stand dann drinne, irgendwie, rechte Foren,
rechte Foren, wie 4chan und Reddit, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, ok, der Autor weiß
exakt wovon er schreibt, vor allem, vor allem Reddit, weil es ja auf Reddit nur ein Forum
gibt, ja, es ist ja bekannt dafür, dass man auf Reddit nur eine Sache in einem Sub-Reddit
schreiben kann, da erkennst du wieder wer der Profi ist, ja, was, sag mal, eben waren
es noch 12 Minuten, wie kann der ein Viertel runtergeladen haben und jetzt, der wird immer
langsamer, chat, seht ihr das, chat, der wird immer langsamer, ah, jetzt wird der wieder
schneller, jetzt geht er ab, jetzt gibt er alles, volle Pulle, juckt euch das auch so
wenig wie mich, was das für ein Typ ist, mir ist die Person hinter dem Emote sowas
von scheißegal, mich juckt der Kerl überhaupt nicht, das ist für mich der PokChamp Emote,
der Rest ist mir vollkommen egal, das kommt dazu, ohne Scheiß, das ist der typische Fall,
hätte Twitch das nicht gebannt, hätte niemand bei dem auf Twitter geguckt, was meint ihr,
wieviel mehr Leute bei dem jetzt auf Twitter waren und haben rumgeflamed oder vielleicht
irgendwie zugejubelt, was auch immer, einfach nur weil Twitch das gebannt hat, vorher hast
du noch mal deine Lizenz, SoftwareKong, SoftwareKong, vertrauenswürdigste Seite aller Zeiten für
CD Keys, oh ist teurer geworden Leute, sehe ich mal 17 Euro, SoftwareKong, jetzt wird er
wieder langsam, jetzt mach hin, auf, ich will den Kram installieren, warum nimmst du nicht
die 64bit Variante, weil Windows XP 64 so ein Nischending war, wo wahrscheinlich auch
vieles nicht funktioniert, wird PokChamp jetzt nicht immer wieder gerne, doch die wollen
angeblich jeden Tag einen neuen PokChamp machen, aber ist immer noch der gleiche wie
gestern, übrigens YouTube Download, das habt ihr ja mitgekriegt, dass YouTube.dl auf GitHub
takedown wurde, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was die offizielle Begründung war, weil sie
in irgendeiner, ich glaube sie hatten in irgendeiner Hilfedatei was falsches drinstehen oder so,
weiß das noch jemand, was da gewesen ist, sie hatten doch irgendwo einen Link auf irgendwas
falsches drinstehen oder sowas, ich krieg sie mal zusammen, warum sie takedown wurden,
zumindest der Witz war, das Projekt, das kannten natürlich eh schon, ein Link zu einem Musikvideo,
sowas war es ja, das Projekt kannten selbstverständlich vorher schon viele, aber seit dem takedown
sind die Userzahlen und der Bekanntheitsgrad nahezu explodiert von diesem Tool und dazu
kam, dass es ja dieses DMCA Repo gibt auf GitHub, wo die ganzen takedown Sachen drin
stehen und irgendjemand hat damals eine Sicherheitslücke auf GitHub ausgenutzt, dass man quasi an
Repos, die einem nicht gehören, Kommentare posten kann, obwohl man das nicht machen sollte,
so und Attachments posten kann, obwohl man das nicht machen sollte, so rum und das war
eine Sicherheitslücke, die wollte GitHub nie schließen und da sind die Leute jetzt
hingegangen und haben den Sourcecode von youtube.dl an das takedown Repo angehängt, als kommend
und siehe da, GitHub hat die Sicherheitslücke gefixt.
Hast du eigentlich deine LED Lasten inklusive Controller fertig? Ja klar, ich hab die am
Fenster am starten, ich hab meinen Weihnachtsbaum dieses Jahr auch mit LED. Wie siehts mit dem
Download aus? Ups, liegt. Ich muss mal wieder fragen, wann CACWSSService kommt. Ja da weiß
ich nicht genau, was wir machen, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt, weil wir haben ja mehr oder
weniger alles schon gemacht, was ich mit CACWSSService machen wollte. Ich wollte ja mal so eine Beispiel
Web Anwendung basteln, so vom programmieren bis zum hosten, die halt einfach nur 10 verschiedene
CACW Varianten ausliefert. Ich glaube, das haben wir schon alles gemacht. Oh jetzt, jetzt
gibt er Gas, 1 MB die Sekunde, jetzt geht er wieder runter. Archive.org, gibs uns, gib
her. Na gut, da müssen wir jetzt auch nicht zugucken in der Zwischenzeit, wo er das macht.
Nochmal zurück, nochmal zurück zu Ebay. Also ich bin da wirklich ganz stark am überlegen,
ob ich nicht meinen Wunschrechner aus 1998 zusammenbaue. Ich mein, man darf jetzt überlegen
nicht vergessen, es ist jetzt über 20 Jahre her, ich bin jetzt ziemlich, ne mehr, ich
bin nicht doppelt so alt, ich bin 3 mal so alt wie damals. Ja so ungefähr, kommt hin.
Da darf ich mir jetzt auch mein Rechner von 1998 bauen. So und wie gesagt, SLI Voodoo
dabei. Eine Sache, die ich aber mache ist, die nicht original 1998 wird, es gibt ein
paar Sachen, aber eine Sache auf jeden Fall, ich mach keine Magnetfestplatte rein, keine
IDE Magnetfestplatte, ich werde gucken, ob ich nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise irgendwie
ne halbwegs aktuelle SSD zu IDE machen kann oder sowas, weil man muss sich ja nicht unnötig
das Leben schwer machen. Auf dem Rechner bootet dann Winos98 in 5 Sekunden und du machst
Ahnung, ist da. Wobei darf man nicht vergessen, das ist ja rein Single-Core gewesen. Winos98,
ich glaub Winos98 konnte noch absolut keinerlei Multicore-Geschichten. Damals haben die gesagt
so nach dem Motto, Multicore bedeutet ja Mainboards mit mehr als nem Socke, weil damals hatten
halt ne CPU nur ein Core und wenn du mehrere Cores haben wolltest, hattest du quasi auch
mehrere CPUs, was ja niemand daheim hatte. Gib Zata zu IDE, ja garantiert. Sowas hier,
zum Beispiel. Sieht natürlich alles extrem High Quality aus, was man hier so sieht. Das
sieht direkt aus wie aus der China-Fabrik. Ja das, die Wartezeiten müssen nicht Winos98-Likes
werden. Da bin ich gar nicht so scharf drauf. Boah ey, sag mal, Download. Come on brah.
Gibt nur so viel random Sachen, die ich schwätzen kann, wie irgendeinem Download. Max, was hast
du eigentlich gegen die China-Fabrik? Die China-Fabrik ist das beste, was es gibt. Ich
hab so viel Zeug schon billig in China bestellt. Wenn es nach mir ging, könnten wir sogar direkt
hier bei mir im Ort ne China-Fabrik aufmachen. Du musst zuschauen, damit er nicht langsamer
wird. Ach ist das so? Solang man draufschaut, wird er nicht langsamer. Ach so ist das. Ja
tatsächlich, guck mal. Jetzt guck ich hin. Jetzt guck ich hin, jetzt wird er wieder schneller.
Jetzt guck ich weg. Jetzt guck ich hin, oder ist er langsamer geworden? Kann doch nicht
sein. So, jetzt guck ich wieder hin. Ich muss die Maus bewegen. Scheiße, es funktioniert.
Ja, wo wir wieder bei der alten Frage sind, Chat. Ist der Mond da, wenn ihr nicht hinguckt?
Man weiß es nicht. Wechselst du zwischen VM und RDP hin und her? Ne. Ich wechsle zwischen
Windows-Desktops hin und her. Guck da, ich hab drei Windows-Desktops und auch den zweiten
Windows-Desktops. Also, wie gesagt, es ist ja trotzdem bescheuert, dass es das virtuelle
Desktop heißt, weil das Einzige, was nicht virtualisiert ist, ist der Desktop, aber unabhängig
davon. Ich hab drei Desktop und die kannst du unter Windows mit Ctrl, Windows-Taste und
File-Tasten kannst du dir durchwechseln. Und hier ist halt mein Linux-Desktop drauf. Und
das gleiche kann ich wieder rauswechseln von der Linux-VM. Das ist insofern ganz praktisch.
Man braucht keinen Dual-Boot, weil Dual-Boot ist Paints-Champ, aber richtiger Paints-Champ.
Und ich kann unter Linux, in der VM mehr oder weniger alles machen, was ich auch so unter
dem nette Windows-Linux machen würde. Und ich kann dadurch, dass der Windows als Host
drauf ist, unter Windows auch alles machen, was ich machen würde. Also für mich ist das
die optimale Kombination. Was ist das für ein Ding? Das ist Manjaro mit E3-WM. Du bist
auch oft genug im Stream, du wirst es da sein, ich wissen. Ne, unter Linux, Windows-VM suckt.
Kannste nicht gescheit spielen drin. Jetzt kommt mir keiner mit GPU-Pass-Through, dann
hast du wieder ganz andere Probleme. Das habe ich tatsächlich auch früher gemacht. Leute,
wisst ihr was mein größter Paints-Champ-Download meines Lebens war? Also der schlimmste Wartedownload
aller Zeiten, der mich echt fertig gemacht hat. Und zwar kein Spiel oder so. Ich wollte
mir irgendwann, wann wird denn das gewesen sein, 1997 oder so, es ist ewig lang her,
ewig lang her, wollte ich mir die erste Version Open Office downloaden. Mit einem 56k Modem
oder einem 33,6k Modem, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, mit einem 56k Modem war
es damals schon. Und das war 190 MB oder so groß. Und habt ihr mal 190 MB mit einem 96k
Modem runtergeladen? Mit einem 56k Modem runtergeladen? Pass mal auf, mal gucken. Wir rechnen mal
aus. 50, guck mal, das gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr. Es gibt überhaupt kein Modem
mehr zur Auswahl. Auf was bezieht sich denn das 56k? Sind das Bit oder? Es sind Bit,
Kilo Bit sind das. Okay, das sind ganz schön wenig. Ja gut, das ist ungefähr so lang wie
heute einer im ländlichen Raum im Osten braucht, um Warzone runterzuladen. 4 Wochen. Kein Ding.
Und damals war, ich glaube, die erste Open Office Version war, ich glaube 160, doch
egal, lang der Upload dauert. Open Office 1.0, wann kam das raus? Gucken jetzt, wie groß
ist das? Wie? Ey! Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das kann nicht sein. Das war viel früher.
Das war ziemlich, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das Open Office war. Open Office. Wann
gab es das erste? Das stimmt nicht. Das war, war früher, das war gar nicht 2012. Ah,
ja, da kommen wir der Sache schon näher. Open Office Org, Open Office Org 1. Download
Size. Ich glaube, das kann man nicht mehr, das gibt es nicht mehr. Keine Chance war das
rauszufinden. Ich glaube, es war um die 160 MB groß. So, und das Problem damals war,
wenn man das mit einem Modem runtergeladen hat, letztendlich ist auch egal, wie groß
es genau war. So, also gehen wir mal von aus, ich habe ungefähr 6,5 Stunden Download, nee,
nicht, Star Office hatte ich damals auf einer CD. Also gehen wir mal von aus 6 Stunden und
hat einer von euch, ich weiß, sie sind ja auch ein paar ältere Leute, hat mal einer
von euch was mit einem Modem runtergeladen, an so einem alten Anschluss, wo du quasi nur
Internet oder telefonieren konntest. So, und wenn du das Telefon abgehoben hast, hast du
Modem Geräusche gehört und wenn du nicht aufgepasst hat mit dem Telefon, dann hast
du das Modem verwirrt und die Verbindung wurde getrennt. Und ich habe Download gestartet,
4 Stunden in hat meine Mutter das Telefon abgehoben, der Download ist abgekackt. Dann
habe ich das ganze nochmal gestartet, dann kurz irgendwie bei frag mich nicht, ist ungelogen
Leute, keine Ahnung, aber 95% im Download ist das Ding abgekackt, hat sich einfach mein
Modem resettet. Ich glaube, das wurde zu warm oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Das heißt, ich
habe dann insgesamt jetzt schon irgendwie 10 Stunden Download geloaded und ich hatte
es nie fertig. Und ich war damals auch so dumm und habe keinen Download Manager verwendet,
das hätte man damals schon machen können. Und es war sogar relativ teuer, müsst ihr
euch überlegen, damals hast du noch Minuten, also du hast damals den Internetzugang bezahlt
und du hast den Telefon-Tarif bezahlt. Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr sicher,
was es gekostet hat, aber das war gar nicht so billig 10 Stunden Internet damals. Du hast
mit einem 10 MBit Modem 60 GBit WarCraft runtergeladen. Ja gut, das geht doch eigentlich noch, ich
meine, das sage ich jetzt auch hier wieder als Boomer, ja. Ich meine, ich habe damals
auch mit, da hatte ich DSL, 756 war das erste DSL, so ungefähr. Runden, wenn wir wohl
wollen auf einen MBit oder so auf. Damals habe ich auch MMOs, Patches und Gedöns runtergeladen.
Also das war 768, genau, ja. Das war auch nicht schön, ja. Aber es ging, es ging, es ging
ja, muss ich mal überlegen, dass man diesen Download Rechner aufbist, der Crempe letztendlich
fertig ist. Also DSL haben die das hier, 1000 gibt es gar nicht mehr. Also runden wir mal
mal. Äh, da brauchst du immerhin noch so in diesem Dreh, ja. Musste da mal, hat, kennt
einer noch die Zeiten zwischen CD und DVD, wo manche Spiele auf 6 CDs ausgeliefert wurden?
Wo du dann immer CDs wechseln musstest, zum installieren. Und ich habe ja damals hier
gespielt, Dark Age of Camelot habe ich gespielt mit dem Friseur zusammen, uraltes MMO. Und
da musstest du dann irgendwann original CD, erstes Addon installieren, nächstes Addon
installieren, nächstes Addon installieren, patchen. Äh, noch, also es war der Wahnsinn.
Wenn du einen PC neu aufgesetzt hast, was ich ja damals gefühlt einmal die Woche gemacht
habe, weil es geht, warst du in halbem Tag beschäftigt. Oh ja, Wing Commander, genau,
das war auch, die hatten damals ja auch noch Filme dabei. Word 6.0 auf 14 Disketten. Ah
ne, da war ich, da bin ich ein bisschen zu, da bin ich ein bisschen zu jung für. Das
einzige was ich da noch mitgekriegt habe ist, wo Leute angefangen haben, Corral Draw, kennt
das noch jemand? Corral Draw? Das war damals der Photoshop der Noobs quasi, also das,
das was Leute heute Affinity Designer haben, ist so, haben die Leute Corral Draw verwendet
und das waren auch irgendwie glaube 20 Disketten oder sowas. Gibt's das überhaupt noch? Okay,
das gibt's tatsächlich noch. Kosten sowas heut? Oh, okay. Bestes, wisst ihr was das
beste, das beste Bildbearbeitungsprogramm war? Ähm, zu den Zeiten wo ich ab und zu
noch mal ein bisschen Lowbob Webseiten gemacht hab. Photo Impact, kennt das noch jemand?
Beste. Photo Impact, Alter. Damit haben die, die Webdesigner Noobs, Webdesign Noob zeugs
gemacht. Da konnte man nämlich, da konnte man nämlich so coole 3D Buttons erstellen,
die ich damals super toll fand, wenn man die auf Webseiten gemacht hat. Ja, so Dinger
hier. Massive, huge 3D Buttons. Ich glaube jeder der IT-affin ist und zu dieser Zeit
am Start war, hatte mal so ne Phase wo er Webseiten gemacht hat. So, ist der Download
jetzt fertig? Ho, Leute wir haben's geschafft. ISO, Windows XP ISO ist downloaded, alles
klar. Also, MD5 Sum, gucken wir mal ob das das echte, richtige, richtige ISO ist. So
wir mal einfach googeln nach der MD5 Sum. Bam. Es ist das echte ISO. Nice. Richtig,
englisches Windows XP Professional with Service Pack 3x86CDVLX1473974. ISO. Alles klar. Gut,
dann kopieren wir das mal raus. Wo ist es denn? Da. Desktop. Da kann ich später löschen.
Ok legen wir mal los. Settings. Desktop. Und jetzt Reboot und wir kriegen hoffentlich
den Installer. Bam, da isser. Massive Installer. Stretch. Jetzt wird gestretched. Sehr schön.
Der gute Windows Installer mit blau im Hintergrund. Hast du alle drei? Aber na klar. Das ist nice,
das ist nice mal wieder zu sehen. Aber müssen wir mal runterschieben. Ok. Das prepared Windows
XP. Alles klar. Press Enter. Was ich damals auch geil fand, ihre obskuren Key Shortcuts
so R, F3. Dann musstest du manchmal zum Treiberladen irgendwann Escape hemmern. Kommt dann auch
die Windows XP Install Music. Die Windows XP Startmusik kommt dann. Bitte Enter über
den Num Block und dann richtig rein hemmern. Gut, weil es da Sebaro ist, für den Sebaro
machen wir das jetzt mal. Also Enter über den Num Block und richtig rein hemmern. Ok.
Alles klar. Machen wir. Pass mal auf hier. Sebaro. Achtung. 3, 2, 1. Knur gehämmert.
Noch mehr hemmern. Ne, mehr hemmern kann ich auf dieser Kacktastatur nicht. Mir ist
einmal schon die Control Taste kaputt gegangen. Übrigens richtig Low Brain. Könnt ihr euch
daran erinnern, wo ich gemeckert habe, dass meine Control Taste abgebrochen ist und nicht
mehr geht. Ich hatte ja die Auswahl, entweder ich schreibe Amazon an und lasse es umtauschen
oder ich gehe an den Logitech Supporten und lasse es umtauschen oder was auch immer. Es
kann ja nicht sein, dass am dreiviertel Jahr die Control Taste abbricht. Wisst ihr was
ich gemacht habe? Ich habe Heißkleber genommen und habe die Taste dran geklebt. Und irgendwie,
weiß ich, was ich genau gemacht habe? Irgendwie habe ich mit dem Heißkleber geleppert oder
so. Geleppert ist ein hessischer Ausdruck für daneber. Ein bisschen zu viel daneber
gemacht. Zumindest hing dann die Taste fest. Dann habe ich ein paar mal auf die Taste drauf
gehauen, dass die Taste wieder locker war und dann hat die Taste nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert. Also sprich, ich habe meine Tastatur kaputt gemacht. Ich hätte es jetzt
theoretisch zurückschicken können, aber ihr kennt mich faul, wie ich bin. Ich habe mir
einfach eine neue bestellt und die andere liegt jetzt hinter mir. So, also F8, wir agreeen
Leute, wir agreeen. Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert. Was passiert, wenn ich sage,
I do not agree? Und haben die hier... Ja, ist klar. Ist klar. Leute, ich glaube, ich habe
dir hoffentlich alles gelesen, ja? Was passiert, wenn ich sage, I do not agree? Oh, er fragt
dich dann gar nicht. Der restartet dann einfach. Okay. Ich dachte, er fragt dich wenigstens
noch. Kannst du noch Microsoft Bob drauf machen? War Microsoft Bob nicht so eine Geschichte?
Was? Press F6? What the hell? War Microsoft Bob nicht Office? Microsoft Bob nicht so ein
Office-Assistent? Okay, nochmal Sebaro hier. Achtung. Bam. Okay, jetzt agreeen wir. Ich
bin in unpartitioned space, quick format. Richtig geiles UI-Design, ja. Und wie? Ha ha, das ist
immer geil. 20%, bam 100. Das waren so die guten alten Windows-Ladebalken. Ihr, it's
ungelogen, Leute, ich habe so oft Windows neu installiert. Ich konnte euch sagen, in
welcher Datei... Also, ich konnte euch mehr oder weniger im Schlaf die Namen der Dateien,
die kopiert werden, aufzählen damals. Ich musste mir diesen Fortschrittsbalken nicht
mehr angucken. Ich wusste anhand der Datei, die kopiert wird, wie weit der ist und wie
lang es noch dauert. Ich habe Windows XP. Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber
ich denke mal, realistisch gesehen bestimmt 200 mal plus neu installiert. Wenn es reicht,
wenn es reicht. Warum hast du das so auf neu gezählt? Weil man damals keine Ahnung hatte
und vielleicht, weil es damals auch was gebracht hat, weil man damals immer, wenn irgendwas
auf dem Rechner nicht ging, Rechner neu installiert hat. Das war Standard. Das hat man seit Windows
8.90 so gemacht oder seit Windows 95. Danach der Motto, du wolltest Half-Life spielen und
das lokale Netzwerk ging nicht, Rechner erscheint nicht in Workgroup, neu installiert. Du bist
nicht ins Internet gekommen, neu installiert. DirectX-Installationsfehler, neu installiert.
Das war normal damals, ohne Scheiß. Das hat man so gemacht. Das Schlimme war, das hat
auch noch erstaunlich oft gut funktioniert. War das nicht übelst Stress? Nö, ich konnte
das im Schlaf. Oh, der Installer. So nice, der Windows XP Installer. Das war kein Stress.
Damals war es ja auch so, dadurch, dass man das so oft gemacht hat, hat man schon seine
Taktiken entwickelt. Man hat einfach alle seine Daten auf eine externe Festplatte, äh
nicht auf eine externe, auf eine zweite Partition geschoben oder auf eine externe Festplatte
oder auf eine zweite Festplatte intern. Und damals musste man noch darauf achten, Leute,
man konnte nicht Festplatten einfach anschließen, man musste noch einstellen, Primary und Slave
IDE. Stimmt es, dass man als Attiler in Frankfurt 400K im Jahr machen kann? Du kannst überall
alles machen, aber der Durchschnitt oder nah an dem Durchschnitt dran ist es definitiv
nicht. Es ist auf jeden Fall ganz schön viel, 400K. Und natürlich kannst du auch in der
IT in Frankfurt 400K machen, ja. Du kannst dein Startup verkaufen zum Beispiel. Oder
du kannst irgendwelche, du kannst der Vorstandsvorsitzende von irgendwas sein. Ach, was weiß ich, aber
du kannst das, für einzelne Sachen gibt es bestimmt, die das machen, aber normal ist
es auf jeden Fall nicht. Oh, oh, wir müssen ja, wisst ihr, wie ewig das damals rumgewurstet
hat? Das kommt, das ist so schnell mittlerweile. Okay, also Format, Units, Neuland, Custom,
Germany. Location. Hat der Location nicht später noch gefragt, wo man ist? Wir sind
in German, Germany. Hat er nicht später noch Location noch mal gefragt? Weiß nicht mehr.
So, Text Input. US muss weg, German Keyboard. Jaja. Okay, wenn das XP Logik, Alter. Ah,
jetzt geht es auf einmal. Okay, next. Name. Cute Chat. Ah, man konnte es nicht skippen.
Cute Chat, da muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz, da muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz ausblenden.
Aber wo habe ich denn, wo habe ich denn den Kram? Wo habe ich denn den Kram? So. Okay,
so. Ja, jetzt muss ich erstmal den Key kurz abtippen, ohne dass ihr den sehen könnt.
OneKS. Forty, wie kommst du denn auf sowas? Diese Keys hat doch niemand benutzt damals.
Ich konnte mein Windows XP Key übrigens auswendig damals, weil ich das so oft installiert habe.
Next. Is invalid. Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Ich finde schon, ich finde schon was, was funktioniert. Ich habe sicherlich noch einen.
Ah, easy. Okay, Leute, wir sind, wir haben es geschafft.
Excellent. Das sind wir. Computer Name. Cute XP. Passwort 123456, 123456. Leaked IP, oh
nein. Wo habe ich denn wieder die IP geleaked, Leute? Wo habe ich die IP wieder geleaked?
Jetzt, Chat, seid ihr schon drin? Schon eingeloggt? Okay, next. Na guck mal da. Also zumindest
ist das da schon mal Windows XP stimmt schon mal. Die Zeitzone ist ja mal übelst fail.
Kona Time. Dabei habe ich gesagt, ich will Currency und Time Format auf Deutsch, aber
gut. Hast du deine Emotes schon im Meme Board? Nee, die habe ich nicht. Die sehen aber auch
groß skaliert nicht gut aus, weil die sind nur 112 mal 112. Okay, Custom Settings musste
man machen, wenn man feste IP vergeben will. Aber ich will keine feste IP vergeben. Ja,
das ist natürlich nicht auf aktuelle Rechner und SSDs gemünzt. Damals konnte man noch,
Leute, ich zeige jetzt mal was. Damals konnte man noch IP, konnte man nicht, kommt man vielleicht
später. NetBios. NetBios, da gab es noch NetBioE und dieser ganze Crap. Ich wollte jetzt
eigentlich IPX installieren, dass wir Half-Life Local Multiplayer spielen können. Von IPv6,
klar. Klar, da sieht man mal, da sieht man mal, wie alt IPv6 ist und wie immer noch nicht
sich IPv6 durchgesetzt hat. Typical Settings wollte ich. Übrigens wusste ich, dass O2
in ihrem Mobilfunknetz immer noch keinen IPv6 hat. Kannst du ein Video zur WhatsApp-Datenschutzlage
machen? Dazu kann ich Folgendes sagen zu WhatsApp-Datenschutz. Ich mache mal den Chat auf, weil WhatsApp-Datenschutz,
ganz ehrlich, die Leute, die WhatsApp benutzen, denen ist es scheißegal mit Datenschutz,
weil, ihr werdet in spätestens einem Monat, zwei Monaten sehen, dass ich recht hatte.
Die Leute machen jetzt einen großen Akt. Eventuell machen die auch einen großen Akt,
ohne zu wissen, um was es überhaupt geht. Und in zwei Monaten verwendet jeder wieder
WhatsApp und die anderen haben keinen User. Die meisten Kacknoobs werden bei WhatsApp
bleiben, die haben da überhaupt keinen Durchblick. In zwei Monaten redet da keiner mehr von. Workgroup.
Workgroup, alles klar. Komm, wie schnell das geht. Komm, wie schnell das mittlerweile installiert.
Das Windows XP hat Kent Royana mitgeliefert. Windows XP hat nur damals dieses Problem gehabt,
dass du ohne NAT davor ins Internet gegangen bist und die Leute ihre Windows XP Rechner
direkt am DSL-Modem hatten und quasi die externe IP, Internet-IP auf dem Rechner war. Das war
eigentlich sicherheitssächlich absolute Zumutung. Windows XP Rechner direkt im Internet. Also,
da muss man sich echt nicht wundern, dass das alles komplett in die Hose gegangen ist.
Was will der eigentlich mit Release-Input die ganze Zeit? Da sollen wir mal auf den Kicks gehen,
da oben. Guck mal, wie schnell das geht. Es hat damals eine Stunde gedauert,
was ich jetzt hier gemacht habe. Ja, das ist nur wegen der SSD. Da flutscht es.
TuneUp Tools, das muss ich mir auch aufschreiben, das brauchen wir. TuneUp 2007. Diesen ganzen
Müll müssen wir installieren zum Ausprobieren. Und Office. Wir installieren eine alte Office-Demo
mit Microsoft Bob. Oder diesem komischen Zauberer. Diffixx wird... Minecraft Demo 2012, sehr gute
Idee, sehr gute Idee. Gibt es hier Wobbly-Windows? Nee, das gab es bei Windows XP noch nie. Improve...
Jaja, mach. Alles klar, perfekt Windows, sehr gut. Windows XP ist das beste Windows, das es je gab.
Leute, ihr schreibt mir das alles mal auf, was ihr hier so schreibt, weil ich das ja dann im
Video zeigen will. Der Hund in der Suche war auch nice. Soll ich... Meine persönliche Meinung,
was Windows GUIs anbetrifft, ist, Windows XP war das beste, was sie je gemacht haben. Das hat
sich irgendwie selbst nicht so ernst genommen in Richtung super krass Business und alles so
noch blau in blau. Die Windows XP-Oberfläche, wie hieß das damals? Luna war das? War das Luna?
Es gab Aero und davor war Luna. Ich glaub, das war Luna, ne? Die XP-Oberfläche. Oh, guck mal,
es gibt sogar Sound, habt ihr das gehört? Click me. Wie? Ernsthaft? Bin zu dumm, ich versteh's
nicht. Was, ihr seht nix? Warum seht ihr nix?
Office 2000, klar, das wird installiert. Ach so, weil der Chat drüber ist. Ja, da gibt's ja nix
Großartiges zu sehen hier. Also, machen wir automatische Updates? Nein, natürlich nicht,
wir sind von der Windows XP, da gibt's gar automatische Updates. Oh, oh, Post-Chat, ob das geht?
ICQ, aber ICQ läuft nicht mehr, es bringt nix, wenn ich das alte ICQ installiere. Okay, was? Yes,
next. Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das noch funktioniert.
What? Hat er sich jetzt registriert?
So, your username test. Thank you. Welcome. Oh, der Sound, habt ihr das gehört, Leute?
Guck mal, hier hat der Hund in der Suche, genau. Oh nein. Erstmal Avira nachinstallieren. Erstmal
Avira nachinstallieren. Jawoll, eine Tour durch Windows XP. Ich weiß, ihr hört nix, ich höre
auch grad nix. Wird ja immer besser. Okay, mal gucken, ob wir überhaupt noch Antivirus
installiert bekommen. Wie, Moment, wie komme ich hier überhaupt ins Internet? Was ist denn
da dabei? Jawoll, Internet Explorer 6, exquisite. Kann man da überhaupt noch Google mit aufmachen?
Oh, unverschlüsseltes Google sogar, Wahnsinn. IE 6, Flash Player, nee, da gibt's ja nimmer.
Kannste gar nimmer downloaden. So, also, als erstes VMA Tools installieren. Wir müssen
VMA Tools installieren. Ohne VMA Tools kannst du es hier knicken. VMS, install VMA Tools,
install. Moment, die Musik, die Musik ist aus, die muss ich neu starten. So, und jetzt
VMA Tools, ah, das sind die VMA Tools, dass ich wenigstens mal ordentliche Auflösung
machen kann. Next, next, next. Wisst ihr was? Die Oberfläche fühlt sich krass schnell
an, ohne Scheiß. Übelst responsive und ohne, ohne, komplett, ohne jegliches Lack. Das fühlt
sich, es ist ungelogen, das fühlt sich schneller an als Minus 10. Macht ja auch weniger. Kennt
jemand legit Seiten zum Kauf von Software Keys? Ja, der offizielle Herstellershop oder
natürlich sowas wie G2A oder wo ich mein Key gekauft habe war bei Software Kong. Allerdings
wie legit die sind, weiß ich nicht. Okay, jetzt müssen wir hier Stretch ausmachen und
jetzt. Aha, Leute, Fullscreen, Windows XP in 1920x1080. Leute, keine, wir machen hier
keine Serial Keys-Sharen im Chat. Was ist denn hier los mit euch? So. Da sind wir, da
sind wir. What a cry musste ich erzählen. Jaja, Windows XP, du checkst es halt einfach
bloß nicht. Jetzt muss ich warten, bis Forever Tools sich gestartet hat. Forever Tools, starte
dich, please. Forever Tools. Aha, sehr nice. Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal einen aktuellen
Browser installieren. Wie installieren wir einen aktuellen Browser, wenn wir nur Internet
Explorer 6 haben? Google. Was ist denn der letzte Firefox XP? Windows, was? Firefox 52
9 ESR. Okay, mach ich. Wo gibt es da ein Download? Hier, bam. Das geht bestimmt mit
Internet Explorer 6 auch auf. Jaja. Okay, Windows. Windows 32 wahrscheinlich. EN ist
okay. Das da. Ah, Zeiten als Browser nur 4843. Moment, wie kriege ich das jetzt rübergemoved?
Sack. Firefox, Poggers. Do not install. Nein, nichts importieren. Oh, das war noch
die Zeit, wo das Firefox GUI gut aussah. Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern? Nein, ich nehme
es zurück. Ich nehme es zurück. Das ist schon die Version, wo das GUI kacke angefangen
hat auszusehen. Das war, wo sie mit diesem komischen Crap-Menü hier angefangen haben.
Nee, aber es war noch nicht ganz so schlimm wie das aktuelle. Das kann man damit jetzt
Google aufmachen mit HTTPS. Ah, yes. Ich stimme zu. So, wichtiges, dass auch EdBlock, nee
nicht EdBlock. NoScript. Allerwichtigstes für Firefox damals. NoScript. UBlock gab es
damals noch nicht. Was soll das? Okay, wo kann man das alte NoScript runterladen?
okay. Hello. Jawoll, jetzt haben wir NoScript am Start. NoScript war das wichtigste
überhaupt, dass man ins Internet gehen konnte damals. Was? Warum? Und jetzt? Will es installieren?
NoScript. Will NoScript installieren. Was ist das hier? Firefox, Alter. Das ist die
alte NoScript-Version. You can still download NoScript Classic. Allow. Ich habe es extra
erlaubt. Ich gucke mal gleich, wie man es trotzdem installieren kann. NoScript ist das
wichtigste, was man gebraucht hat damals. Okay, also was? What types of add-on is, where
is it? Was? Wie? Aha, okay. AboutConfig, jawoll. Ja, except. False. Ja, exellent, exellent.
Muss man Firefox dafür neu starten? So, alles klar. Download. NoScript. Es gibt keinen
aktuellen... Wenn es den aktuellen Firefox gäbe, dann würde ich den noch nehmen. Install.
Oh, da ist es. Da ist es, der klassische NoScript. Beste. Jawoll. Jawoll, so muss der
sein. AllowGoogle.de. Nein. Okay, wollen wir mal gucken, ob YouTube noch geht? Das
müsste noch funktionieren. Es ist neu genug. Das sollte noch funktionieren. Aber es ist
halt lahm as fuck, ne? Ja, gar kein Problem funktioniert. Und? Hey, guck mal, es läuft
sogar, sogar 2K Video läuft halt. Okay, flüssig ist jetzt was anderes, aber. Soll ich das
mal im Internet Explorer 6 aufmachen, YouTube? Gucken, was dann passiert. Oh, oh. Ist es
überhaupt die E6? Ja, das ist die E6. Oh. Das geht nicht, das redirectet immer klar.
Nee, das funktioniert nicht. Okay, also YouTube und so funktioniert alles klar. Sehr gut.
Cool. Kann man auch rechts klicken für die Stats? Man kann leider die letzte Session
nicht mal aufmachen, das gab es damals noch nicht. Aber man kann in die History gehen.
Damals war das übrigens sogar noch Single Threaded und hat übelst rumgespackt. Was
in die Video Stats gehen? Ja, auch hier. Und jetzt 2K Video oder Windows XP. Funktioniert
erstaunlich gut. Ach guck mal, Twitch, Twitch und Bloats. Twitch müsste aber auch funktionieren.
Okay, da muss jetzt erstmal NoScript alles erlauben. Das war halt das Coole an NoScript.
Ich weine NoScript immer noch ein bisschen nach. NoScript war beste, except. NoScript
beste. Muss man erstmal alles erlauben, mühsam. Ich benutze NoScript nicht mehr, seitdem
sie die Arp hier umgestellt haben. Und seitdem NoScript nicht mehr getaugt hat, als es neu
war. Mittlerweile geht es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Aber ich habe jetzt U-Block. So, jetzt
ist die Frage. Geht das Video noch oder geht das Video nicht? LimeWarrior. Da könnte
man auch gleich Beershare benutzen. Kennt noch jemand Beershare? Okay, ich mache mal
kurz, ich mache mal kurz U-Block aus für die Seite. Ging das nochmal? Okay, dein Username
geht schon mal gar nicht. Nee, okay, nein, Twitch geht nicht. Twitch geht nicht. Max.tv
ist echt down, wirklich? Sebaro, was ist da los? Stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. Passt doch
alles, ist nicht down. Geht doch. Ganz Chebader hier wieder im Chat. Also wunderbar, das funktioniert
alles. Also jetzt probieren wir noch ein paar Sachen aus, die der Chat vorgeschlagen hat.
Und zwar die Minecraft Demo aus 2012. Wo geht es denn überhaupt zum Down? VLC brauchen
wir mal natürlich. VLC, was denn sonst? Läuft der aktuelle VLC noch unter? Geht der wirklich
noch? Geht der aktuelle VLC noch unter Windows XP? Run. Tatsächlich, okay, man kann den installieren.
Webplugins lassen wir mal weg. File Associations machen wir mal nicht. Wahnsinn. Moment, da bin
ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert noch. So, basic as fuck, ist VLC nicht? VLC
benutzt zum Beispiel GPU-Beschleunigung zum Decoden und sowas, das ist gar nicht so basic.
Und VLC, da ist er. About. Er geht? Geht einfach. Winamp. Wobei, ich hab gar kein Winamp mehr,
ich hab FUBAR 2000 damals, wer kennt jetzt noch jemand? FUBAR. FUBAR 2000, beste. Übrigens,
wir müssen, wir müssen ganz wichtig, Windows XP ist so am Meckern, wir brauchen, wir brauchen
Avira. Avira Windows XP müssen wir installieren. Was? Wollt ihr mich rollen? Download.
Jawoll, Avira 2014. Kann man auch noch das aktuelle downloaden? Oder unterstützen die
das noch? Sagen sie Tschüss zu Betrüger und Hackern. Avira 2014 laden wir jetzt runter,
nur von Chip. Ok, was gibt's denn, was gibt's denn, was gibt's denn da noch? Old Versions.
Ah, VG, Free Anti-Virus, Ok, ich will Avira haben, ich hatte früher immer Avira. Ich
hatte früher immer Avira, auch wenn's übelster Crap ist. Ah, guck mal, hier kann man auch
runterladen. Ah, was? Kostenlos downloaden. Alles klar. Fast geschafft. Ja. Ok, das, das,
das können wir, das können wir theoretisch. Ich will aber Avira, gib her. Haben die keine
alten Versionen einfach noch? Ah, gib her. Download. Avira. Run. Oh, geht nicht.
dann lad ich mich jetzt von Chip, dann lad ich mich jetzt von Avira 14 von Chip
runter. Bäm, das wird immer schlimmer. Download. Jawoll. Auch noch ne Beta. Nee, komm, wir
installieren jetzt, Avast Free. Avast hab ich noch nie installiert, aber muss. Was wäre
Windows XP ohne so einen Crap-Viren-Scanner? Gab's nicht Defender für, gab's? Gab's
Windows Defender für XP? Wirklich, das brauch ich. Das brauch ich. Gab's Windows Defender
für XP? Wirklich? Gib her. Defenders Defender. Sicher ist herunterladen mit Avira. Ja, ich
wollte ja, ich wollte ja. Hallo? Ah, aha, ok, Moment, Moment. Ja, ja, ich erlaube Chip
mal kurz. Jaja, Cookies, Cookies alle. Gib mir den Windows Defender. Jawoll. Auf. Chip.
Hat er das Binary da grade angezeigt? War das das Binary? Hat der grade das Binary runter
geladen? Keckweg, Alter. Safe Link erst. Ja, ok, das wird schonmal, das wird schonmal
nix. Wo kriege ich den Windows Defender her? Windows Defender, Windows XP. Netzwelt.
Windows Defender download Speedup. Netzwelt. Wisst ihr was das geile ist? NoScript nervt
mich schon so sehr wie damals. Klingt ultra safe, ne? Netzwelt. NW Windows Defender. Das
sind wir. Moment. Soll ich das wirklich ausführen? Ah, komm, YOLO. Erstmal, erstmal, erstmal
Netzwerk ausschalten, man weiß ja nie was man sich da einfällt. So, Disconnect. Tatsächlich,
der echte Windows Defender. Verstehe den. Jawoll. Da machen wir halt Netzwerk wieder
an. Ups. Ok, awasst, verpiss dich. Weg. Ja. Empfohlene Einstellungen verwenden. Jaja.
Jedoch kein Mitglied bei Microsofts Binet werden. Nein, ich möchte kein Mitglied bei
Microsofts Binet werden. Ich finde das klingt auch in heutigen Anbetracht der Tatsache etwas
ähm, wie sagt man so grotesk, so Windows Spinet. Die, die meinten damals natürlich
dass sie nicht sie auf dich spyen, sondern die Viren auf dich spyen, aber heute sieht
das ein bisschen anders aus. Windows Defender, easy. So, weiter gehts. Minecraft Demo 2012
und ganz wichtig, Windows, oh, oh, oh, Moment, da kommt man nicht einfach so tippen. Ähm,
das die Suche des Programms nach der, wie das wurde abgeschaltet? KegWade. Was soll
das hier, Anzeige ist raus. Ich glaube es geht los. Not found. Wie der erkennt seinen
eigenen Windows Defender nicht oder wie? Ok. Dann, dann deinstall, dann installier ich,
dann deinstallier ich jetzt den Windows Defender und installiere Avast. YouTube geht, YouTube
ist gar kein Problem. YouTube funktioniert, das haben wir schon ausprobiert. Avast, wo
ist es hier? Nee, nicht Avira. Ah, Avast. Sebaro, was ist das? Das, das, das letzt,
läuft das unter Windows XP? Läuft das unter Windows XP Sebaro, was du da hast? Nee, oder?
Ok, nein, nein. Ok, aber übrigens wisst ihr was wir machen sollten? Wir sollten mal ganz,
ganz dringend, bevor wir den ganzen Crap hier machen, mal einen Snapshot anlegen, dass ich
dich neu installieren muss. Ok, install, install, Avast, Alter, komm her, let's go Avast. Oh,
Moment. So, und damals hatte ich übrigens kein Win-Amp. Win-Amp, Windows XP, Download, Chip. Guck mal, Chip. Win-Amp, full. Win-Amp, Win-Amp, Win-Amp. Und dann irgendwas, bla, bla, bla, Lama S. Wie ging das nochmal? Win-Amp, Win-Amp, Lama S, irgendwas. Jetzt sind wir zusammen.
It really whips the Lamas ass, genau. Win-Amp. Win-Amp 5.8, jawoll. Beste, das brauchen wir. Die Win-Amp 5.8 Beta.
Was? Aber machen sie sich keine Sorgen, klicken sie einfach aktivieren. Sie sind gefährdet. Warum?
Warum bin ich gefährdet? Sag's mir doch. R.C. Bauer probier ich später noch aus. Nach Leistungspro... Alter, gehen wir nicht auf den Sack. Ganze, ganze Crap. So, ich hab das eigentlich nur aus Nostalgiegründen, normalerweise wird es gar nicht mehr zählen. Win-Amp 5.8, Download, Chip. Genau, alles von Chip.
Dann entweifle ich auch die Beta, ist auch okay. Safe. Moment, Moment, das ist nicht der richtige Win-Amp. Das ist der Fake Win-Amp. Was war die letzte gute Win-Amp-Version? Win-Amp, was war ein guter Win-Amp? Win-Amp 4.
Old version. Win-Amp, was war eine gute Win-Amp-Version? Muss irgendwie so... Windows XP Release, wann war das 2002 oder 2001? Okay, hier irgendwie. So, da. Win-Amp 3. Win-Amp 3.
Meinst du, das ist Jebait? Das ist ein Virus-Domain. Keine Ahnung. Win-Amp, 4 Players, Win-Amp 2.77, jawoll, die brauchen wir jetzt. 4 Players, das liest doch auch keiner mehr, oder?
Ja, wir sollten noch zwei weitere Anti-Viren-Programme. Aber guck mal, Windows ergibt sich jetzt zufrieden mit Anti-Virus. Guck mal, wir haben eine Anti-Virus-Protection.
Win-Amp. Ah, das muss schön hässlich und alt aussehen, genau. Advanced Virtual Visual... AOL.
Das AOL-Alken. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Gehen wir nicht auf den Sack. Ja, so ist das gut. Jetzt kommt jetzt... Wo ist das Lama? Da ist das Lama.
Genau. Moment, ihr habt es nicht gehört. Ich mache lauter.
Genau. So muss das sein. Jetzt sind wir gut unterwegs unter Windows XP. Win-Amp. So muss das sein, ja.
Jawoll. Ok. Damals hat jeder auch noch Diffix und Xwit gebraucht. Das installieren wir jetzt nicht, weil wer weiß, wo ich da rauskomme.
So, und was ich auch noch erzählen hatte, war Dings. Ich hab dann später aufgehört Win-Amp zu verwenden, hab nur noch FUBAR verwendet. Mal gucken, ob man das noch unter Windows XP überhaupt installieren kann.
Wo gibt es die alten Versionen? FUBAR. Old. Old. Old Versions-Page. For Windows XP-Users.
Habt ihr... Hat jemand von euch auch FUBAR verwendet? Ich fand das dann irgendwann viel, viel besser als... Moment, das ist das Falsche, oder? Ne. Als Win-Amp.
Benutzt du heute noch? Ok. Beste hier. FUBAR. Guck mal, da hatte sogar eingebautes Darksteam. FUBAR Music Player. Eine Sache, vielleicht fällt euch was auf, die Software von damals hatte viel mehr Optionen und Einstellungsmöglichkeiten.
Das lag daran, weil der Gram noch nicht für Tablet-Bedienung optimiert war. Und es war damals übrigens auch normal, dass man hier unten so eine Startleiste hatte, die von da bis da ging. Weil sich alles irgendwie in der Tastleiste verewigen musste.
Ok, Minecraft Demo 2012. Download Minecraft Demo. 4MB.
Willst du die Minecraft Demo? Welcome to Minecraft PC Gamer Demo. Das ist doch irgendwas.
Minecraft Demo Version 1.5. Ok, Moment, da müssen wir jetzt erstmal gucken. Ist das die richtige?
Da muss ich bestimmt Java vorher installieren, hä? NEIN! Ok. Java 1.5. What the f...
1.5. Gibt's das überhaupt noch? Kann man Old Versions runterladen? Denn die aktuelle wird nicht funktionieren unter Windows XP.
Oder? Oder? Oder? Postchamp? Postchamp? Nein. Ok. Java 1.5 XP Download. Offline Installer?
Ja, hat auch keinen Unterschied. Was oben rechts? Alle Java-Versionen? Ah, hier.
Ok. Äh. Nein. Ok, das könnte funktionieren. Hä?
Ok, wo kriege ich denn den alten Crap her? Chip. Einfach Chip, Alter. Ok. XP. Nein.
230 Spitt. Ne, das wird auch so nicht mehr funktionieren. Nein, es muss doch einen Java 1.5 geben. Java 1.5. Beheben. Runterladen.
Chip-Installer-Exe? Was ist das? Das ist irgendeine Chip-Geschichte? No. Piss dich, Alter.
Ah, Java Archive-Downloads. Exzellent, exzellent. Jawoll. Ähm. 15. Für? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nicht x64, x64. Wir brauchen x32.
Ne, nicht 15. 5 ist das Richtige, ne? 5. Ah, hier. Guck dir mal, guck dir mal. Windows-Offline-Installation.
Das da brauchen wir. Ja, ja. Alles klar, Oracle. Macht keinen Akt. Oh Gott, jetzt wollen die, dass ich mich einlogge.
Ich nehme das, was da Sebaro kopiert hat. Sebaro weiß, was er macht.
Soll ich das wirklich runterladen, Sebaro? Bist du dir da so sicher?
San. Du hast doch Avastia, da kann nichts mehr passieren. Stimmt, das war noch von San damals. Das war ja noch gar kein Oracle. Stimmt. War noch gar kein Oracle.
Ich nehme das vom Sebaro. Der Sebaro weiß schon, was er macht. San. Ähm.
Aber das muss bestimmt mit Punkt x umbenennt oder sowas, oder?
Ah, BigBrain-Windows-Logik. Okay, except. Typical, jawohl.
Was man damals für Crap noch machen musste. Zu geil.
Aber warum will Oracle, dass ich mich da einlogge? Ich meine, was ist mit euch verkehrt?
Okay, Minecraft. Ich hatte es schon installiert, oder?
Ah, geht trotzdem, geht trotzdem. Alles klar. Juckt ihr nicht, juckt ihr nicht, ist ihm egal.
Alter, meine Maus. Das liegt an der FVM, das liegt an der FVM, dass das mit der Maus nicht richtig geht.
100%.
Das liegt an der FVM.
Was, F4? Und dann passiert nichts. Settings, Options. Äh, Sensitivity. 14.
Okay, schon besser. Boah, ist das schwammig. War das schon immer so schwammig?
Boah, Alter, das ruckelt out of ass. Fuck, ey.
Boah.
Die Maus ist schwammig wie ass. Fuck, ey. Ich kann nicht steuern.
Das liegt an der FVM. Also das liegt an der FVM. 100%.
Kannste nicht steuern, das ist unmöglich. Aber, wo ist der Unterschied zu heute? Sieht doch immer noch so aus.
Oh, ist komplett abgekackt.
Drück F3. Ich hab F3 gedrückt und es ist nichts passiert. Was soll passieren, wenn man F3 drückt?
Also, dass es voll am Abspacken ist.
Oh, jetzt ist es kaputt, Chat. Jetzt ist es kaputt. Eben ging es noch, jetzt ist es RIP. Ist auch egal. Aber es wird theoretisch funktionieren.
Ist ja schon mal was. So, jetzt probieren wir Office aus. Ganz wichtig erst mal nochmal hier das...
Konnte man hier nicht unter Windows XP schon so einen Quick Lounge machen? Oder musste man das erst einplanten?
Ah, hier. Okay, EE raus. Winamp raus. Guck mal, damals konnte man noch richtig Sachen ordentlich tracken und droppen in der Taskleiste.
Und die Taskleiste machen wir mal ein bisschen fetter, ein bisschen dicker. Falls das überhaupt ging.
Nee, die konnte man nicht dicker machen, die Taskleiste.
Wollt man die dicker machen? Also man kann die ziehen, aber das bringt nichts. Dann ist die Schrift ja nicht größer.
Appearance? Font size, large. Ist das jetzt größer? Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied. Ah doch, da unten. Aber in Fenstern bleibt es doch gleich.
Das hatten damals manche coolen Leute. Die hatten es in Silber. Aber ich mochte das Default. Ich habe immer das Default gemacht.
Stimmt, DPI Scaling Settings. Wo war das denn? Advanced, DPI Settings, large. Genau.
Okay. Yes. Ist es jetzt larger?
Yes. Dimm, dimm, dimm, dimm. Jetzt installieren wir Office noch. Gab es da auch eine Demo?
Was war denn da für ein... Office 2000 oder 2007? 2007 war das mit Ribbon Bars, glaube ich. Office 2007 war das erste mit Ribbon Bars.
Oh, die Media Center Edition war cool. Die hatte ich im Wohnzimmer damals. Ist meine Mutter überhaupt nicht mit klagekommen.
FireFox kaputt. Oh, wir haben fette Fonts eingestellt jetzt. New Updates are ready to download.
Java, ich glaube dir das jetzt einfach mal. Warnung, ihr System ist ungeschützt. Oh mein Gott, jetzt ist vorbei.
Wo ist das Problem? Avira, warum? Ach, aktivieren. Das glaubt ihr aber auch selbst nicht, oder?
Ah, jetzt bin ich geschützt auf einmal. Eben war ich da noch ungeschützt. Guck mal, was ist das? Man darf das nicht mal wegmachen ohne weiteres.
Und was hat das Java Zeugs jetzt gemacht? Hat das jetzt downloaden im Hintergrund?
Okay, ICQ und Skype. Skype können wir machen? Nee, Skype für XP gibt's nicht mehr. Skype Classic, jawoll.
Okay, wir erlauben, wir erlauben es immer. Aber Skype, Skype muss sein. Ja, ja. Download. Auf Chip. Gib alles.
Warum braucht der Download Java Skript? Er musste mal Chip fragen. Ich weiß es nicht. Skype Full. Run.
So, und jetzt Office. Office 2000 ISO Download. Jetzt will er auch bei Archive. Jawoll.
Äh. Machen, würden wir nie machen?
Wo ist das Download? Ein Zip? Ein fucking Zip? Ernsthaft, ja? Wow. Das ist mir doch ein bisschen lang jetzt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
51 Minuten? 41 Minuten? Ich glaube, das lade ich woanders runter und zieh's dann da rein. Aber erst mal Skype installieren.
So sah der Skype Installer aus. Genau. I agree. Next. Ich download es mit Download Manager Unterdienungs, dann geht das besser.
Office 2000 ISO Download. Jawoll. Da gab's auch einen SP für? Wirklich?
Ach, deswegen ist es ein Zip, weil es beides ist. Äh. Wie kann man das jetzt, wie kann man das jetzt machen?
Dann stört's rein. Copy Download Link. Abbrechen und dann sagen wir mit Download Manager gehen wir da jetzt ran. Sagen Download. Damn. Was?
Hä? Seht ihr Leute? Schon geht das Ganze ein bisschen schneller.
Äh. Ähm. Nee, Vorti, der macht doch standardmäßig schon acht und wenn das nichts bringt, dann bringt das hier wahrscheinlich auch nichts.
Ich meine, ich kann's ausprobieren. Was, S ist Speed und X ist wie oft er forken soll?
Moment. Wait a minute. Was sind das für Settings? Warum geht das jetzt so schnell?
Warum flutschten das jetzt so? Moment, was hab ich da? Top 10 Settings Download Manager, ja. Also Minus X macht was? Max Connections.
Und dann hab ich Minus S. Macht was? Minus S. Minus S. Was ist Minus S? Q Chat sagt Split. Ah, mehrere Connections.
Ich dachte man konnte Minus J machen. Aber das ist ja nice. Easy as fuck. Okay, während das Download gucken wir was unsere Skype Installation macht.
Your Firefox ist out of date. Ho. Nein. Nein. Was, Firefox? Wie kommst du auf die Idee? Wir haben Skype am Start, Leute. Oh.
Cancel MIP Change Notify. Kann Skype nicht starten. Oma, Dissortion, fünf Monate, Dankeschön. Change MIP, Cancel MIP, das suchen wir jetzt danach.
Also wie heißt das Ding? Cancel MIP Change Notify 2. Warum geht das nicht? Define a winner's vista or later. Oh, okay.
RIP. Es ist nicht mit XP kompatibel. Oh. Ja, okay, da wird das mit Skype schonmal nix. ICQ können wir auch gleich vergessen.
So die Minecraft Demo auch ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig was wir wollen. Tune Up 2007, Leute. Das allerwichtigste.
Freenet. Jawoll. Das brauchen wir. Das ist wichtig. Ohne. Ohne. Jetzt nicht. Wo ist der Download? Demo. Jawoll. Download. Die allerwichtigsten Sachen für Winners XP.
Also, nee, ernsthaft, installiert euch so ne Scheiße nie. Download. Auf, gibs mir. Ja. Hier, gib. Jawoll. Tune Up 2007, trial.de.
Excellent. Mein Vater hat früher immer Tune Up installiert und hat gesagt, immer wenn er das nicht einmal am Tag ausführt, dann ist sein PC langsam. Totaler Schwachsinn, das was sein PC langsam gemacht hat, war dieser Crap.
QChat. QChat lizenziert das. Ja, kein Problem. Na klar. Symbol zur One-Click-Wartung. Der Tune Up Schredder. Na selbstverständlich wollen wir das alles installieren. Gibt es eine Alternative zu Skype? Ja, neues Skype.
Das geht dann auch. Oder halt einfach Discord. Fertig. Tune Up Utilities. Update Prüfung. Ja, natürlich. Wie hat man noch mal Updates gemacht unter Windows XP? Wo waren denn die Windows Updates hier?
Kann sich da noch irgendwie einer dran erinnern, wo das ging im Security Center vielleicht?
Wo konnte man noch mal nach Updates suchen lassen? Windows Update. Wo ging das denn noch mal?
Windows Update gibt es da nicht. Ach hier. Ah, stimmt. Nee, das geht garantiert nicht mehr im Internet Explorer. Wie?
Wie das? Was ist hier los? Tune Up? Tune Up? Warum geht's nicht? Warum hat sich Tune Up kaputt getune Upped?
Was ist das hier? Anzeige ist raus. Wir starten es jetzt trotzdem. Jetzt bestellen. Ja. Komm. Auf geht's.
Okay. Weiter testen. Okay, dann lass uns mal tunen, Leute. Dann lass uns mal tunen. Aufräumen und reparieren.
Das Tune Up System Control Center. So eine Scheißsoftware. Ich kann immer mal verstehen, warum man diesen ganzen Kack damals verwendet hat.
Das ist mir absolut unbequem. Wo wir da dabei sind, damals konnte man richtig coole Sachen einstellen in der meisten Software.
Jetzt nicht, dass das eine coole Software ist, aber naja. Der Tune Up Styler 2. Oh ja, das brauchen wir.
Index XP Tunen. Der Tune Up Styler. Jawoll. A busy, klein, visueller Style. Das ist ja einfach die offiziellen Dinger. Man konnte allerdings damals, glaub...
Ich glaub, man konnte damals noch Sachen nachinstallieren. Effekte und Zeug. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr, aber...
Der Serious Twitch Prime. Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich guck mal schnell, was ich übersehen hab. Die Surface Packs brauchen wir nicht mehr. Das haben wir schon, das neueste.
Das Tune. War Soon Tune, oder wie man das ausbringt, nicht dieser Windows Media Player? Hunter, 1998. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, das Tune. Wie spricht man das aus? Tune, Tune, Soon. Team für Windows XP, das brauchen wir unbedingt. Ganz wichtig. Soon.
Gibs mir Chip. Auf. Chip, für so ne Kacke. Ok, aber dieses Tune Up Ding ist komplett unsinnig, oder? Wozu, was genau ist die Daseinsberechtigung des Tune Up Styler 2s?
Was genau ist die Daseinsberechtigung? Das kann ich doch alles über das Standard Windows machen. Es ist überhaupt kein Unterschied. Warum? Wozu soll ich das Ding verwenden?
Äh, ich will ein Video machen zu Windows XP. Ok. Das war's, Download. S-Top-Ziem-Punkt-was-M-S-I. Jawoll. Da haben wir's.
Damals konntest du Windows noch einfach mit einer Dateienendung was unterschieben.
Das Tune-Tune-Desktop-Ziem. Jawoll. So ist das gut. So ist das nice. Lai. Jawoll. Das Tune-Ziem. Wobei der Hintergrund hat gesackt.
Dann immer weiter das da. Oh, äh, Stretch. Jawoll. Hier. Das war Darkseam damals.
Massive Style. So, wie sieht's mit unserem Office-Download aus?
Download completed. Ah, nicht Explorer. So, also. Jetzt, wisst ihr was ich noch nie probiert hab? Ich hab noch nie probiert von einer VM in die andere was rein zu track and dropen. Ob das funktioniert?
Office Professional Track and Drop. Hier, oder? Das geht nicht. Das wär auch zu abgedreht.
Erst mal hier hin. Jetzt darüber kopieren.
Was für eine Distro benutzt du auf deinem Hauptsystem? Windows 10.
Windows 10 ist hier drauf. Und das was du meinst, hier, das Andean, das ist auch eine Linux VM. Der Linux VM ist Manjaro mit i3-WM drauf.
Was machst du? Windows XP noch mal angucken. Weil ich ein Video machen will zu Windows XP und einfach mal ein bisschen gucken was ich da zeigen könnte.
So, jetzt installieren wir erstmal Office. Welches Windows 10? Das ganz normale. Professional.
Aber ich hab das abgecreated mit einer Windows 7-Lizenz damals. Sonst ja machen.
Guck mal. Stimmt, es gab ja damals schon ein ZIP-Programm. ISO. Oh nee Leute. Moment. Wie hat man noch mal ISOs gemountet unter Windows XP?
Demon Tools oder sowas brauchen wir dafür jetzt. Demon Tools Light brauchen wir jetzt, genau. Ist das gerade ein bisschen mal abstürzen? Kann das sein? Nö, sieht nur so aus.
Kennt noch jemand dieses CD-Brennprogramm? Wie ist denn das? XP-Burner oder so? CD-Burner XP, genau. Beste, beste.
Nero hatte ich auch. Aber dann hab ich irgendwann festgestellt, das reicht. Jawoll, CD-Burner. Als Software noch 5 MB groß war.
Yes. Das gibt's bestimmt nicht mehr zum Downloaden. Nein,.NET Core. Haha, so siehts Microsoft aus. Okay. Windows.NET XP 4. Wo gibt's das zum Downloaden?
Was? Englisch. Ja, ja.
Oh, x8664. Vielleicht geht's ja auch so. Accept, alles klar. Ich kann zwar nichts lesen, aber ich accepte. Ich accepte alles. Alles gut Microsoft, wird alles accepted.
Nee, Vierer gab's anscheinend auch noch für XP. Zumindest kann man's installieren.
Oh, es gibt ein Update für Silverlight. Ja, endlich. Da hab ich drauf gewartet.
Okay, während das jetzt installiert, können wir mal gucken. Google. Demon Tools Lite war das zum ISO-Smart, ne? Demon Tools Lite XP Download.
Ja, Chip. Heute ist aber Chip gut dabei. Wow, die Software, was? War das so? Ernsthaft, war das so?
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern. Virtual Clone Drive.
Ja, ich kann über vm eine ISO machen, das ist aber nicht original. Das hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Kenn ich nicht, das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus. Lern ich auch mal wieder was Neues.
Nein, nein, nicht der Chip Installer. Nicht der Chip Installer. Gibt's das auch als normale? Ja, ich will nicht den Chip Installer haben.
Ich mal. Arschlecken, Chip. Okay. Run. Ich stimme zu, na klar. Jaja, mach mal, mach mal.
Alter. Treiber wird installiert. Continue. Versuche mal auf der Originalseite, was fand von Demon Tools.
Der Chip Installer ist einfach ein Virus. Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was der Chip Installer ist, aber ich sehe den Sinn nicht von einem Chip Installer.
Oh, das.NET Framework ist auch drauf. Da können wir jetzt ja, da können wir jetzt ja mal die ganzen Kram starten. So, also als erstes wollten wir, nein.
Moment, weshalb hab ich noch mal eben.NET installiert für CD Burner. CD Burner XP brauchen wir. CD Burner XP.
Jaja. Full Installation gibt's mir.
Yes, genau so sah das aus. Daten zusammenstellen, Video DVD, ISO Image brennen.
Sehr nice. Sehr, sehr nice. Okay, so. Und jetzt mounten wir uns die Windows XP, äh, die, die. Der Sound.
Ja, jetzt kann man ISOs einfach mounten, aber Windows XP ging das noch nicht. Oh, nee. Braucht man da wirklich ein CD Key für? Ach, Microsoft, please.
Da muss ich wieder in meine alte Kiste gucken, ob ich da noch ein CD Key habe.
Selbstverständlich gebe ich dir jetzt ein Original Legend Windows XP, äh, Office-Dings ein. Ich meine, was erwartet ihr sonst von mir?
Natürlich, klar.
Das ist keine Demo.
Selbstverständlich legit.
Äh, moment, jetzt muss ich den CD Key mal eingeben. Da könnt ihr jetzt nicht gucken, weil Windows 2000, weil Office 2000 ja auch garantiert das ist, was jeder von euch mal gerne piraten will.
Keine Serials posten, Leute. Keine Serials posten.
Weg, Sebaro. Lösch mal die Serials. Dankeschön. Kann man nicht machen. Es ist zwar so alter Crap, den keiner verwenden will, aber man weiß nie, welcher Stonks man das vielleicht mal sieht.
Und der Meinung ist, dass, äh, zwar eine 20 Jahre alte Software, aber das geht ja auf gar keinen Fall.
Next. So. Zufälligerweise hatte ich noch einen Office 2000 Key, den ich euch jetzt nicht gezeigt habe.
Also install now.
Auf geht's. Install, installiere mal.
Diese Installer Menüs, ne? Ich hab schon wieder verdrängt, wie die aus, also jetzt, wo ich sie sehe, aber genau dieser komische Balken, das hat mich damals schon immer getriggert, dass dieser komische Balken überhaupt nicht in das restliche Windows XP Design gepasst hat.
Weil guck mal, wenn wir jetzt umstellen, ähm, auf, auf, was? Hä?
Windows XP wieder. Ignore. Hä?
Das war übrigens damals normal, dass Windows öfters mal Fehlermeldungen geschmissen hat und das trotzdem ging.
Früher hat man nicht Wikipedia geguckt, früher hatte man noch Encarta, genau. Warum gibt's eigentlich eine CD2, was ist denn da drauf?
Und was hat er jetzt überhaupt installiert? Ah, Word, PowerPoint, Excel. Was ist, was ist auf, ah, äh, äh, äh, äh, okay, er zeigt den Key nicht.
Visio bestimmt, hä? Was, was ist denn?
Was ist denn auf der Office CD2, da muss ich mal kurz, kurz drauf gucken, jaja. Äh, Moment, wie hat man den Explorer überhaupt aufgemacht?
Konnte man sich den nicht irgendwie auch hier unten da in die, ähm, bei Computer?
Open. Was ist denn da drauf, sieht man das? Der EE5 ist da drauf, oh, jawoll, jawoll.
Schriften. Ist da kein Visio drauf gewesen?
Office, Disc 2? Visio, ich will Visio haben.
Ach nee, da waren Cliparts und so ein Crap drauf, ne?
Visio, jawoll, alte Crap. Okay, so, also gucken wir jetzt mal, Word.
Oh, da ist er, da ist er.
Jaja, Accept, Accept. Wie konnte man den Kram nochmal umstellen? Choose Assistant.
Nein.
Oh, die hatte ich immer.
Den Zauberer, gibt's den Zauberer gar nicht mehr?
Gab's nicht, gab's da nicht mal einen Zauberer oder war das noch früher? Das gab doch einen Zauberer.
In der Suche war der Hund oder konnte man den auch umstellen?
This feature is not installed. Yes.
Okay, welche, welche Sache muss ich jetzt einlegen?
Ich will die Cat installieren für Windows XP.
Oh Leute, ich hab's gecrashed. Das war keine gute Idee.
Okay, andere Disk einlegen.
Windows, please. Vielleicht muss ich doch wieder Disc 1 einlegen.
Jetzt ist vorbei. Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich's kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's gekillt. Jetzt ist vorbei.
Ah, geht. Nice.
Gag W in 2021.
Oh, er hat einen Tipp. Er hat einen Tipp für uns. Exquisite.
Just press enter to accept completion. Okay.
Was es alles kann. Was es alles kann. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Okay. Oh.
Und in der Suche konnte man den Zauberer umstellen?
Ah.
Und die Katze ist da auch am Start.
Das ist der Zauberer. Genau. Die Katze ist aber nicht wirklich animiert, oder?
Die Animation von der Katze ist kaputt.
Search the Internet.
Was?
Suchen Sie jederzeit auf Bing.
Okay, das funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Search.
Ich will den Zauberer haben.
Okay, das Teil kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern. Das Teil auch nicht.
Ich kann mich nur an den Zauberer erinnern.
So. Windows XP war weniger Stonks.
Network Places. Erkennt das wenigstens auch die anderen Rechner bei mir im Netzwerk?
Das ist vorbei.
Okay, Leute, was haben wir denn sonst? Also wir haben Office installiert.
Wir haben Office installiert. Wir haben sonst viel. Wir haben die Minecraft Demo gespielt. Die hat funktioniert.
Was muss ich installieren, damit OpenAL64 funktioniert?
Gar nicht, oder?
Weil 64 geht nicht.
Minecraft Demo XP 32 Bit.
Ja.
XP tatsächlich.
Nicht kaufen. Downloaden. Computer Bild.
Oder ist 116 das aktuelle?
Minecraft Excel.
By the way, wollte Java sich nicht eben upgraden?
Wollte sich Java nicht eben upgraden und hat das nie gemacht?
Wo ist das denn überhaupt, Leute?
Wo ist denn mein Java hier jetzt überhaupt zum...
Seht ihr das? Gibt's Java?
Java hat sich verabschiedet, hat gedacht, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Kram.
Ach stimmt, das war... Ah, da ist es.
Hat das denn jetzt geupgraded? Nee, 1.5.
Das wollte sich doch eben updaten. Hier.
Ah. Download.
Das macht er einfach nicht. Okay, okay.
Und dann.
Okay, der Download geht einfach nicht mehr. Aber warum sollte man auch eine Fehlermeldung ausgeben, wenn der Download nicht mehr funktioniert?
Ja, AnyDVD war auch cool. Aber das Zeug bringt jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Weil man kann jetzt mit DVDs ja nichts mal zeigen.
Okay, Baro, können wir machen. Ich geh jetzt gleich was essen, dann können wir noch ein paar Runden spielen.
So, also was, was können wir noch so... Was können wir uns noch angucken?
Also, tune up den ganzen Crap hatten wir uns ja auch schon angeguckt.
Dass die Leute da so scha... Okay, Moment, was macht denn...
Ich will das nicht bestellen. Beenden. Was macht denn die One-Click-Wartung?
Weiter testen. Ohje.
Ich brauch keinen Tune-Up-Code.
42 Probleme gefunden. OMG.
Microsoft Sam? Moment, wo konnte man Microsoft Sam noch mal umstellen? Wo ging da Sprache?
Boys? Nee. Oh nee, das finde ich, das finde ich nicht mal. Speech? Speech.
Okay, da hat sich, da hat sich schon saumäßig viel getan in den letzten Jahren, oder?
Also, mittlerweile hört sich Microsoft Sam deutlich besser an.
Ich mein, heute hört sich Microsoft Sam so an. Moment. Ich hab doch hier irgendeinen Microsoft Sam drinne.
Cute Chat. Kann er das vorlesen?
Cute Chat in Wireless.
Okay. Oh, Wireless Setup. Was macht der da? Er kann ja gar nichts.
Windows XP, willst du nicht vielleicht checken, ob ich überhaupt die Hardware dafür am Start hab?
Ich hab überhaupt keine Hardware für Wireless drin.
Okay, jetzt mal gucken, was Tune-Up gefunden hat.
Also, einfach Problem beheben? Was?
Aha. Alles klar, okay. Und was haben wir hier Anwendungsprobleme gefunden?
Vielleicht irgendwelche Debug-Symbols oder sowas?
Für den OpenML-Fehler von Minecraft? Ah, excellent. Aber das geht's für XP nicht mehr geben, oder?
Doch.
Aha. Okay, das sieht eher aus wie Windows 3.11. So schnell?
Ah, 3D Mark können wir noch machen. Aber 3D Mark in der VM?
Okay, wir machen erstmal Probleme beheben.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob Minecraft mit Sound läuft.
Vielleicht muss er einfach neu starten.
Was haben wir ein Problem, dass Windows 10... Moment, was?
Haben wir ein Problem, dass Windows 10 nicht mehr reparieren werden kann?
Das Problem der Festplatte ist nun... Oh, das ist schlecht, das ist die Festplatte im Arsch.
Das Beste, was du machen kannst, wenn du wirklich den Kram brauchst und auch Geld in die Hand nehmen willst,
dann würde ich die Festplatte nicht weiter verwenden, sondern jemand geben, der sich darauf spezialisiert hat.
Aber, äh, ja. Oh, Minecraft ist jetzt RIP, geht das gar nicht mehr.
Okay, probieren wir 3D Mark 2001. Download. Das wird aber in der VM nicht funktionieren, oder?
Das wird aber teuer, verstanden. Also ich würde das nicht machen für irgendwie 0x15 Zeug.
Also wenn das Zeug nicht so wichtig war, was du da drauf hast, dann würde ich jetzt auch einen Apfel beißen und demnächst Backups machen.
MadOnion. Yes. Yes, weiter. Google Toolbar für je.
Haben wir jetzt schon einen neuen PokChamp? Ich guck mal.
Immer noch der gleiche Typ von gestern. Wollten die das nicht ändern?
Command & Conquer 1. Nee. Purchase later.
Mal gucken, ob das in der VM läuft. Ich mein, VM unterstützt Diret X, aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie das unterstützen oder wird aus XP.
Abloss, das läuft jetzt. Was haltet ihr davon, in einem Server SSDs im Raid einzusetzen? Das ist top.
Es flutscht, Leute. 118 FPS.
Das war damals die größte Poggers-Grafik auf diesem Planeten.
Passt zu der Grafikkarte. Das kannst du mit Desktop-Virtualisierung und VMware Workstation leider nicht machen.
Mal Crysis testen. Crysis Demo.
Hatte Crysis eine Demo?
Abbrechen. Abbrechen. Hatte Crysis eine Demo?
Nee, das läuft nicht.
Das läuft nicht.
Damals hatten Spiele noch Demos.
Jetzt erst mal die Auflösung hochstellen.
Wo konnte man die Auflösung hochstellen, Leute?
Oder hat er das von alleine gemacht?
Okay, das hat immer alles nur 4 zu 3 Auflösungen.
Klar.
Yes. Endlich mal.
Oh, jetzt sind Fullscreen. Der Grümli. Prime, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich meine, für 2001 geht es doch noch voll klar mit der Grafik, oder?
Was? Oben? Ernsthaft? Kommt man oben 16 zu 9 machen?
Wo?
Ah, hier. Lul.
Ich meine, guck mal, ohne Scheißsonne für 2001 geht die Grafik doch voll klar.
Du hast wahrscheinlich Fake-Spiegelungen in den Autos.
Dann guckt euch mal die Physix an, wie die rumjumpen.
Havok konnte damals einpacken.
Ja. Danach spielen wir die Crysis-Demo. Die läuft nicht in der VM.
Hörner vergessen.
Der Halo kam vor allem auf der Xbox raus.
Damals ist einem voll einer abgegangen, wenn man so Grafik-Demos gesehen hat.
Ah, das kenne ich noch. Das ist, wo der Drache im Kreis fliegt, ne?
Ja, genau. Das kennt noch jeder von damals. Leute, ich wette mit euch.
Jeder, der damals einen Gaming-PC hatte, der kennt das noch.
Wo man auf dem Drache geflogen ist. Klar, da kann ich mich doch dran erinnern.
Der macht dann ein Looping am Ende, glaubt sogar noch.
Guck mal hier, 400 FPS.
Hi-Rez. Hi-Rez-Bodenzeugs. Ground-Units.
Von den Bogenschützen, ja.
Guckt euch hier den PC-Models an, Alter.
Aber nicht, dass du trotzdem drum herum, das war so, auch von Beleuchtung her und so,
für die damalige Zeit echt richtig geil.
Lobby.
Ah, Matrix stellt.
Quasi Max Payne Light.
Das gab es hier dann fast 1 zu 1 in Max Payne, ne?
Und Max Payne 1 sah auch fast genauso aus. Max Payne 1 gab es ja auch so ein Lobby-Shootout.
Irgendwie ist das richtige Potato-Grafik, das ist 2001 Massive Graphics gewesen.
Faster Than a Ferrari. Computer Gaming World. Habt ihr das jetzt gesehen?
Guck mal, 100. Und die Spiegelung auf dem Boden hier.
Tja, damals ist dann bei der Grafik mega einer abgegangen.
Damals bis voll ausgerast bei der Grafik. Ich warte jetzt nur bis die Crysis-Demo runtergelaufen ist.
RTX On, Leute. RTX On.
Du hast letztens Max Payne 3 gespielt. Warum? Codz-Emoji?
Das sah doch ganz gut aus. Oder meinst du Max Payne 3 an sich vom Game her?
Ja, war ich auch nicht so begeistert von. Aber ich fand es nicht so richtig schlecht.
Guck mal, das sieht doch sogar ziemlich gut aus.
Landschaftsstell. Breath of the Wild kann einpacken.
Vor allem bei dem hochdetalierten NPC da unten auf der Bank.
Der Bart, Alter.
Und der Berghintergrund. Aber immerhin schon.
Witcher 3 Vegetation.
Das sieht aber schon durchaus in Ordnung aus.
Meine Spiegelung hatten wir damals halt noch nicht so richtig.
Das sieht jetzt tatsächlich ziemlich gut aus, weil du halt nicht viel erkennst.
Dann kommt der Fillrate-Test.
Welche GTA-Generation war neu? Wahrscheinlich San Andreas oder so in dem Dreh?
Alter Epilepsie-Warnung, please. Aufhören.
Noch mehr. Das hört gar nicht auf.
Mit wie viel FPS lief der Benchmark? Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber ich denke mal, wahrscheinlich auf ein guter System genauso schnell.
Das ist halt immerhin eine VM.
Oh, jetzt kommt der High Polygon Count.
Oh, ist ja Massive High.
Die Models sehen halt jetzt ein bisschen besser aus, wie damals.
Wie viel RAM? 4G.
Was bei dem 32G-System vielleicht jetzt. Wir können mal gucken, wie viel nutzbar ist.
Das ist eigentlich nur noch mal ein Benchmark-Score. Das könnte mir jetzt einfach mal ein Benchmark-Score geben.
Dann probieren wir Crysis aus.
Ja, die Fallenweber Workstation macht DirectX-Translation-Gedöns.
Was soll denn das überhaupt sein?
Also Fallenweber Workstation kann irgendwie DirectX on the fly umschreiben oder so.
Das sieht aus wie ein Versteiner der Kackhaufen.
Test Completed 13.07.17. Okay, wir haben es bald.
Guck mal, und da zeigen sie uns ihren Battlefield-Trailer mit 128 Spielern.
Das gab es schon 2001. Easy. Gar kein Problem.
Ey, das sieht ja tatsächlich mal ziemlich gut aus.
Finde ich auch. Das sieht wirklich gut aus.
Für 2001 sieht das massive aus.
Okay, noch zwei Tests, dann haben wir es geschafft. Advanced Pixel-Shader.
Oh, wir haben Spiegelung. Und wir haben wahrscheinlich 5 FPS oder so.
Sea of Thieves kann einpacken. Gut, die Hintergrundbäume vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Jetzt ist RTX on gewesen. Ein Test noch. Und Fish AI.
Max versucht Pferdesounds zu machen.
Okay, was haben wir? Score? 19.000 3D Marks. Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
3D Mark 2001 Score.
Oh, 145.000. Man müsste TNT 1, was hatte denn TNT 1 damals gehabt?
Score.
Okay, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht. Wir haben 20.000 und der hatte damals mit seinem System 8000.
Also so schlecht ist das gar nicht mal, was wir da jetzt gekriegt haben.
So, jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage. Geht die Crysis-Demo?
Nee, das ist nicht CPU only.
Das ist der Virenscanner, der muss Crysis jetzt scannen.
Nee, aber vor allem, wer kann das? Das kann DirectX irgendwie translaten und Gedöns machen zu deiner Host-GPU.
Okay, next.
Winrar. Nee, so einen Kack brauchen wir nicht.
Wenn schon, brauchen wir Winzip, genau.
Try it for free, Winzip.
Wir brauchen Winzip.
Glaubst du eigentlich, dass ich Game Streaming durchsetzen wird? Du meinst, wenn du mich jetzt im Jahr 2001 gefragt hättest?
Dann hätt ich gesagt, nee.
Oh, IE 8, oh higher.
Okay, Moment. IE 8 XP, download.
Okay.
2 in 3 spit, 2 in 3 spit, 2 in 3 spit please.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen? Da kommen wir jetzt in der Trommel rum.
Da kommen wir jetzt in der Trommel rum. Wir müssen jetzt IE 8 installieren.
Jawoll, so ist gut.
Was?
Ernsthaft? War das damals echt ein Ding? Ging das nicht?
Die Uni Regensburg, Internet Explorer.
Internet Explorer 8 von der Uni Regensburg, jawoll.
Für XP.
Ah, sehr gut. Die Uni Regensburg saved uns, dass wir Winzip installieren können.
Okay, nein, nein, ich will nicht partizipieren.
Accept next.
Das wird nicht funktionieren, das war mir schon klar.
Wahrscheinlich brauchen die das heute noch, deswegen gibt es das da zum Download.
Ach, Games in der Cloud laufen lassen? Nein, das glaube ich nicht, dass ich das durchsetzen wird.
Oder siehst du ja auch bei Stadia, dass das kaum einer spielt.
Schon gar nicht mal mit dem Internet.
Mit dem Internet hier in Deutschland.
Restart? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, wir restarten jetzt, alles klar.
Dann installieren wir, dann ist Crysis, dann können wir Crysis danach starten.
Wir haben schon das neuste Service Pack für XP.
Windows XP ist shutting down.
Ja.
Aha.
Da sind wir wieder.
Cyberpunk auf Stadia läuft gut, dann ist Stadia die einzige Plattform, wo es gut läuft anscheinend.
Okay, er meckert irgendwie wegen Skyprom, kann ich mitleben?
Warten wir erst mal, dann wird Crysis gestartet Leute, Crysis.
Electronics Arts, Crysis, jawoll.
Pog, Pog, Postchamp, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Oh, das scheint zu gehen.
Aber meine Maus packt halt rum, ich muss die andere Maus durchreichen.
Guckt es euch mal an, es ist Crysis.
EA.
Ach nee, das war noch die Zeit, wo sie nicht die ganze Zeit EA gesagt haben.
Mhm.
Dort wo Crytek noch Geld hatte, ja.
Das stimmt.
Wo Crytek noch nicht 50 Studios auf der Welt aufgemacht, oh.
Alter, könnt ihr mal hinmachen und ich darf das Spiel starten?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Guck mal, das hört gar nicht mehr auf mit Dingern.
XP Cute Seems, ja wenn du da eins hast.
Options, okay jetzt erst mal, jetzt erst mal hoch drehen hier.
So, Blut.
Blut.
Yes.
System Settings, Graphics.
Wollt eigentlich Reap Voice haben.
Auflösung.
Okay, es gibt, gibt keine.
3840 mal 1400 natürlich, was sonst, ach guck mal da.
Anti-Elasing Quality gibt es nicht.
Yes.
Advanced, Medium, Medium, wir lassen es mal auf Medium, wir wollen es jetzt.
Leute, gibt es irgendwie bei Crysis so einen Overlay?
Bei nehmen brauchen wir noch gar nicht, wir können doch hier.
Einblenden.
PS Counter.
Single Player.
Easy.
Ja komm, Gaming Journalist Mode.
Guck mal, wie das einfach läuft in der Form, aber eine Maus wird halt nicht funktionieren.
Vorgas Intro.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das Schlimme ist, dass Crysis immer noch ziemlich gut aussieht, auch für 2021.
Jetzt wartet mal Leute, bis Ingame Graphics kommen, ob das wirklich auch so gut läuft.
Das ist ja noch ein Video.
Am Anfang, ich weiß noch damals, man startet ja im Heli oder im Flugzeug, ich bin mir ganz
sicher, wo man dann runterhüpft.
Und am Anfang, wenn die Tür noch zu ist von dem Flugzeug, läuft alles gut.
Sobald die Tür aufgeht und man den Strand sieht, ruckelts.
Aber Leute, die haben gesagt, dass Crysis im Prinzip so eine Engine Demo, so eine Graphik
Demo war eine spielbare.
Okay, please, lass mich das überspringen oder irgendwie mal Ingame.
Ich mache mal ganz kurz die Musik hier aus.
Prerelease Demo, press any key.
Okay, meine Maus kann ich nicht verwenden, weil meine Mausgarantie drumspackt.
Das ist aber in der VM so.
Ich kann mir aber einfach eine Maus durchreichen.
Skip.
Oh nein, ich darf nicht skippen.
Doch, ich darf skippen.
Exquisite.
Eh mein, 90 FPS.
Aber wie gesagt, im Flugzeug am Anfang ist das alles gut gewesen noch.
Das ist Prophet.
Das war Prophet, oder?
Ingame etwas lauter, wir spielen letztlich die Story.
Das sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Überlegt mal, das kam, wann kam Crysis?
Das ist in der VM, ja.
Wann kam 2007?
Kam Crysis.
Oh meine Maus, MonkaS, meine Maus.
By the way, damals ist mein Rechner übelst eingebrochen.
Aber komm, die FPS sind absolut in Ordnung.
Weißt du was?
Leute, wir probieren mal kurz die...
Ich probiere mal was mit der Maus.
Warte mal, ich probiere mal was mit der Maus.
Ich schließe mal eine Maus an und reiche die an die VM durch.
Das müsste ja funktionieren.
Achtung, kannst du mal dran gehen Maus, please?
Oh Crysis ist gecrashed.
Äh, naja.
Ähm, so.
Ok, Geräte.
Wie ging das jetzt hier nochmal mit dem Durchreichen von...
Crysis ist eigentlich ganz nice, ja.
Provable Devices.
Ha, das ging doch, man musste doch irgendwie erstmal sagen, zeige alles an.
Ähm.
Ha, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Man konnte Mäuse durchreichen.
War das nicht in VM-Einstellungen?
Achso, nee, nee, nee, man kann das durchreichen, removable devices.
Wie ging das denn nochmal?
Das ist echt in den Settings?
Und jetzt?
Ah, show all USB-Input-Devices, ja gut.
Ok, wir müssen mal die VM kurz abschießen.
Power off.
So, und jetzt?
Show all Input-Devices, jawoll.
Jetzt können wir nämlich auch die Maus durchreichen.
Jawoll, äh.
G403 müsste es hier sein, ja.
G403.
Also.
Erkennt er die jetzt?
Ok, da muss die Maus erst noch erkennen, das dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Aha, wir haben eine richtige, eine gute Maus, die da voll und ordentlich funktioniert.
Ok, Crysis, wo ist die Crysis-Demo, easy.
Hoffentlich hat er gespeichert, sonst muss ich den Kram wieder wegklicken.
Please, please, skip, lass mich skippen, alles skippen, skippen, skippen, skippen.
Mal kurz gucken, wie gut das läuft, alles skippen, skippen, alter Hacker-Man, Hacker-Man, skippen.
Ich darf nicht skippen.
Leute, ich darf nicht skippen.
Skippen ist, skippen ist not allowed.
Load Game.
Ah, der hat gespeichert, exellent.
Da muss ich den ganzen Kram nicht neu machen.
Ich meine, für eine VM läuft das wirklich erstaunlich gut.
Das hat anscheinend Autosave, ja, ich bin selbst.
Ja, da sind wir, guck mal, jetzt kann ich die Maus auch richtig steuern.
Move, look around, ja.
Night Vision, alles klar, ich kenne mich aus, ich bin Crysis Pro.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, wie gut das läuft, wenn man auf dem Boden ist.
War das normalerweise im Intro nicht hell?
War da nicht Sonnenaufgang eigentlich?
Oder bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Aber das kommt dann ziemlich am Anfang, dass Sonnenaufgang ist, oder?
Das Wasser ist ein bisschen kaputt, wisst ihr was?
Also wir haben jetzt hier, wir haben jetzt erst mal kurz die Schildkröte own,
der das vollkommen egal ist, ob ich auf so schieße oder nicht.
Ah ne, it's a dead, it's a dead.
Oh, da fehlen auch auf dem Boden ein bisschen was, oder?
Kannst du das aufheben? Kommt mir die echt auf? Ich komme blöd dran, oder?
So, wisst ihr was, wir stellen jetzt mal High Settings ein.
Options, Settings, erst mal gucken, ob Bluteffekte und so an sind,
weil die Schildkröte hat, weiß nicht, ob die Bluteffekte beste.
Also wir spielen das jetzt, ich will nur mal kurz gucken, wie gut es läuft.
Graphics, All, High, kann man nicht einfach alles?
High, a very high geht nicht.
Yes. Okay, Leute, jetzt ist vorbei.
Cineastische FPS, aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, wisst ihr, dass man sich damals gefreut hätte
über 33 Crysis in High?
Damals hättest du es da ausgeflippt, wenn du Crysis mit 30 FPS hättest spielen können in High.
Hättest du dich gefreut?
Nice, okay, zack, aus ist genug Crysis, aber cool, dass das funktioniert,
auf jeden Fall, schau mal, Poggers.
So, gibt es noch irgendwelche Dinge, die wir unbedingt ausprobieren müssen mit XP?
Also wir haben hier sogar Office aufgelistet.
Ach so, meint der IE8, ist IE8 jetzt installiert?
Ist das jetzt schon IE8?
Oh, es ist IE8.
Battlefield 3, das kriegen wir, glaube ich, nicht mehr installiert ohne XP.
Mit Origin und allem.
Kannst du die Minecraft-Demo probieren?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass die nicht mehr startet, das ist irgendwie kaputt jetzt.
Die startet nicht mehr.
Die ist RIP.
Die ging einmal und dann nie wieder.
Aber Winzip muss man noch ausprobieren.
Welcome to Winzip.
Allerwichtigste überhaupt.
Neues Pog, echt?
Das geht sogar, das geht sogar, das neue Pog.
Das ist besser als das letzte Pog.
Also merken wir uns, ich habe noch den alten Pog-Champ bei mir.
Wobei, das kann sein, dass es gebuffert ist.
Ja, bei euch ist aber der andere.
Ich glaube, dass die sogar mittlerweile X11 oder X12 schon können, aber nicht alles davon supporten.
Das hast du ja auch an dem Boden gesehen, dass teilweise Sachen gefehlt haben.
Okay, jetzt haben wir das allerwichtigste Programm schon mal drauf, Winzip.
Endlich haben wir mal Winzip drauf.
Use Evaluation, Winzip, jawoll.
Exquisite, das wollte ich schon immer haben.
Ne, Minecraft ist kaputt jetzt, das geht nicht mehr.
Und um nicht zu vergessen.
Nochmal für alle.
Der Sound ist so geil.
Kann man eigentlich eine VM in der VM schon?
Ja, kann man machen, aber das wird nicht besser davon.
So, ICQ geht nicht, ICQ läuft nicht mehr.
OBS-Studio.
Den Windows Messenger, jawoll, den brauchen wir unbedingt.
Get a.NET Passport.
Ach, das war die Zeit, wo sie alles irgendwie.NET genannt haben, weil es irgendwie cool war.
Okay, läuft nicht mehr.
MSN Messenger ist RIP.
Übrigens, mit der Zeit hattest du ja hier unten, diese ganze Bar ging dann bei manchen Leuten irgendwie bis hier.
Es gibt ja sogar Leute, da ging die bis hier.
Die konnten genau zwei Dinge aufmachen, weil die Bar zu groß war.
Movie Maker, stimmt, wo ist der Movie Maker?
Den musste man zusätzlich installieren, kann das sein?
Den musste man zusätzlich installieren, ne?
Oder war der Sound?
Media Center SP Crisis Demo.
Hä?
Was macht die Crisis Demo da?
Tja, wo ist der Movie Maker?
Entertainment?
Communications?
Links ist der Movie Maker, echt wo?
Ach, da!
Excellent.
Oh, da sind wir.
Jetzt brauchen wir erstmal ein Video, um das da reinziehen zu können.
Haben wir irgendwelche Demos?
Bei Videos?
Bei Music?
Sample Music?
Beethoven, ja genau, Beethoven.
Ah, yes.
So.
Jetzt noch Bilder bei.
Pictures.
Sample Pictures.
Sunset.
Ja.
So, top Video haben wir gemacht, top Video.
Top Video.
Direkt Upload auf YouTube.
Ok, probieren wir jetzt nochmal eine Sache aus, kann das gibt's?
Too smart.
Emote.
Was?
Das Emote ist not found?
Leute, geht das bei euch noch?
Too smart.
Doch, da.
Oder ist es doch?
Oh, Monka Toss hier.
Alter.
Ich will keine Kinder mit Pampers ansehen, ey.
Das wird dir wirklich mal Monka Toss langsam.
Ok, GIF Image.
Mal fort hier.
Downloads.
Ok, kann das jetzt?
Jawoll!
Ah, jetzt und das Ganze jetzt natürlich mit Beethoven.
Jetzt haben wir exquisite Video erstellt.
Jetzt ist alles gut, jetzt haben wir Windows XP voll ausgereizt.
Ja, Vegas hat heute noch Probleme mit manchen GIFs.
Premiere Vegas, die können alle einstecken.
Windows Movie Maker.
Das passt doch zur Musik richtig gut.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich den Stream zusammenschneide oder ob ich das nochmal
neu aufnehme für YouTube hier.
Ich glaube, ich nehme das nochmal neu auf.
Oh, wir brauchen, Leute, wir brauchen ganz wichtig, eine Sache brauchen wir noch.
Pinball, ja 3D Pinball.
War das dabei?
Oder muss man das nachinstallieren?
Games.
Pinball, da ist es.
Übertreibt man nicht.
Oh ja, der Fullscreen hat sich jetzt richtig gelohnt.
Ah, Moment.
Z?
Ride Flipper gibt es nicht, okay.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Hallo?
Alter, die Taste geht nicht.
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Warum kann ich das nicht bewegen?
Ich bin zu low-brain dafür.
Aber ganz wichtig, eine Sache brauchen wir noch.
Eine Sache.
Ich habe unter Windows XP Webseiten gemacht.
Wir brauchen Makromedia Dreamweaver Download.
Dreamweaver 8.
Moment, das ist ein Buch.
XP.
Real Player.
Oh, oh, oh.
Kann man da eigentlich einfach DE wegmachen oder geht es auch noch?
Scheint.
Dreamweaver 4, jawoll, das brauchen wir unbedingt.
Mit dem Real Player früher Pots...
Na dann.
Ich glaube, ich habe den Real Player installiert gehabt, aber nie großartig benutzt.
Okay, lass mich downloaden.
Dreamviewer, jawoll.
Das ist der beste Webseiten-Editor damals.
Ich habe was drauf, ich bin eh safe, kann mir nichts passieren.
Genau.
Eine Nummer.
Habe ich da nicht eine Demo?
Ernsthaft?
Demo.
Okay, Leute.
Zack, Zack.
Ich habe sicherlich noch einen Key dafür.
Dreamweaver 4.
Das geht schon mal nett.
Natürlich alles original rumliegen.
Okay, das geht auch schon mal nett.
Ja, für die Version habe ich anscheinend kein günstgültiges Serial.
Ja gut, dann kann ich es euch nicht zeigen, aber das war Pog Web Editor damals.
Oh nein, ihr habt nichts gesehen.
Ihr habt ja auch wirklich nichts gesehen, der Bildschirm ist ja noch aus.
Tja, gut.
Das kann man, getFlash, kann ich mir Flash installieren?
Die Seite lebt noch nicht mal mehr.
Ah ne.
F vorbei.
Ich habe das Schauscript schon freigegeben.
Aber wie gesagt, Dreamweaver war damals Massive Pog für Webseiten bauen.
Was für eine Scheiße schon alles installiert.
Vor allem das Schlimmste ist, wir haben ja allen Ernstes Internet Explorer 8 installiert.
Das letzte Internet Explorer, den es für XP gab.
XP.
Warte, der letzte Internet Explorer für das ist 9?
Neckt.
Das hat auch Microsoft voll verkackt.
8?
Ok, Internet Explorer 8 ist der letzte, alles klar.
Das kann man da drin YouTube abspielen im EE8?
Was?
Beta erinnern.
Ja, geh weg.
Mach auf.
Mach gefälligst was ich gesagt habe, mach die Seite auf.
Was?
Display Content.
Als wäre YouTube das Problem.
Internet Explorer, du bist das Problem.
Nicht YouTube.
Ok, nope.
Not supported.
Gibt kein YouTube mehr.
YouTube vorbei.
Kann ich direkt ein Video aufmachen?
Flash ist tot.
Leute, kein YouTube im EE8.
Aber wenn ich ICQ installiere, muss ich ICQ installieren.
Ich bin so boomer, ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
ICQ 2003, beste.
So, das war das eins schwere ICQ.
Genau das da.
Das Problem ist, das geht nicht mehr.
Weil die haben ICQ für die alten Version abgeschaltet.
Aber was natürlich noch geht, ist das allerwichtigste ICQ Sound.
Ich würde sagen Leute, das brauchen wir ganz dringend hier noch drinnen.
Also, YouTube.
Und hinzufügen.
Kennt ihr noch Sumo Volleyball?
Leute, kennt noch jemand Sumo Volleyball ICQ?
Beste.
Jetzt kann ich euch nerven.
Wenn irgendwie was ist.
Oh no.
Hat das jetzt eigentlich Tom geloadet?
Ich dachte, das wäre mein ICQ.
Zum Verwechsel ähnlich.
Was damals auch voll angesagt war, dass die alle so komische Installer gemacht haben.
Eine hässlicher als der andere.
Aber Leute, was soll ich sagen?
Sumo Volleyball.
Bestes Game.
Blobby Volley war auch okay.
Aber Sumo Volleyball hab ich in ICQ immer gespielt, wenn uns langweilig war.
Das ist eins, das ist von diesen ICQ Games gewesen.
Leider, New Register hier geht das nicht mehr.
Man kann sich da leider nicht mal anmelden in so einem alten ICQ.
Aber ich kann euch noch ein paar mal ICQ sounden.
Vergiss den.
Oh, der ist gut.
Leute, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Irgendjemand hat mein dummes Geschwätz im Stream Remix.
Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht spielen.
Das ist Monka Toss.
Wo ich den ICQ Sound nachgemacht hab.
Das kann ich ja nicht spielen.
Das ist Monka Toss.
Heutzutage geht das nicht.
Langsam wird unsere Windows XP Leiste so, wie sie sein muss, einfach zugemüllt mit irgendeinem Crap.
ICQ war in vielen Sachen, finde ich, auch ein bisschen ihrer Zeit voraus.
Auch, dass sie so eigene Gameplattformen hatte und sowas.
Aber die haben es halt verkackt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo genau es schiefgegangen ist bei ICQ.
Ich glaube, bei ICQ ist es schiefgegangen, weil die zu lange gebraucht haben für Voice Chat.
Die sind zu Skype gewechselt wegen Voice Chat.
Und heute sind sie alle bei Discord.
Die haben die Spiele entfernt, ernsthaft.
Das war eigentlich das Beste.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Die Poggers-VM ist busy.
Zauerei.
So Leute, schön, dass so viele am Start waren.
Ich gucke, dass ich da irgendwie ein Video draus zusammenwursten kann.
Also, ich werd den Stream nicht zusammenschneiden.
Ich werd wahrscheinlich das Ganze noch mal neu aufnehmen.
Und dann furchtbar Fake-Reacten nach dem Motto.
Hab ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Dabei hab ich den Stream schon angeguckt.
Jetzt weiß ich aber zumindest, was ich zeigen kann.
Ja, meine ICQ-Nummer weiß ich ja auch.
Die sag ich euch aber nicht, weil wenn ihr meine alte ICQ-Nummer kennt,
dann findet ihr meine alten Forums-Account und MMO-Geschichten,
wo ich der übelste Spaß war und die Leute geflamet hab
und teilweise richtig dummes Zeug geschrieben hab.
Ohne Scheiß, mir sind manche Sachen so peinlich,
wenn ich die lese von mir.
Was ich da teilweise vor 30 Jahren geschrieben hab.
Nein, 30 Jahren nicht, aber vor 20 Jahren geschrieben hab.
Es gibt von mir einen Newsgroup-Eintrag zu Mario64.
Und da hab ich mich über die Leute lustig gemacht.
So richtig assi, die keine 120 Sterne hatten.
Da war ich, keine Ahnung, 14 oder so.
Hab ich dann sowas gesagt wie, he he.
So sinngemäß hab ich so was geschrieben.
He he lol, ihr habt keine 120 Sterne.
Ha ha ha ha, habt das schon ganz lange oder sowas.
So richtig dumm, so richtig, was so ein 14-jähriges Kind schreibt.
So richtig dämlich.
Ha ha ha, ist richtig eng geblieben.
So, strieben der Friseur, dann haust man den Friseur.
Auf geht's.
Der Frasier, da ist er.
Wie, der spielt schon wieder BDO.
Was ist denn los, hat ihn jetzt wieder der BDO-Kick erwischt oder was?
Gucken euch an, da wird BDO gestreamt.
So, wir raiden jetzt den Frasier, bam.
Dann könnt ihr ihn voll spammen mit den neuen Emotes, die wir haben.
Plus den Patrick mal fragen, ob wir neue Emotes, ob die schon was gemacht hat.
Okay Leute, also wir sehen uns.
Bis denn, zu Waffen von dem Set wird es so auch geben.